ừ ừ
à à
anh alo alo chào các bạn ạ
à Hôm nay được trước khi mình bắt đầu
học thì mình muốn chia sẻ một vài thơ tí
không ạ anh tâm sự chia sẻ một tí
tiên thì mình cho mình cho mọi người gặp
qua cái này trước đã
đọc qua rồi cho không nó hết đâu mình
cho mình đọc gói gọn gợi ý chí cho
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Ừ
thì em xin lại nói qua được à những
người đang dạy làm giàu nhưng mà người
để rất nghèo
A và
cái cái bài đăng này thì tóm gọn lại ý
nghĩa là kéo rất nhiều người đang lại
đang dạy làm giàu ấy nếu họ thu tiền của
mình và họ làm giàu từ cao họ làm giàu
trên bản thân của chúng nghĩa là làm
giàu trên tiền người khác ngày ngày lúc
mà họ đang dậy là họ hiện tại họ không
giàu họ không phải tấm gương khác phải
khác học
này họ chưa đạt được thành tựu gì trong
cuộc sống thì họ lấy gì zậy người khác
này
A và
ừ ừ
Ở
đây họ lừa phing người nhẹ dạ cả tin và
lần bà cái quan trọng hơn đó là họ hướng
đến cái mục tiêu không phải là hướng đến
mục tiêu là là sẽ hiện sẽ khiến các bạn
giàu lên mà hướng đến mục tiêu lấy tiền
được các bạn có những người thực sự giàu
sẵn rồi và họ muốn chia sẻ bí quyết đó
các bạn ấy thì ra lại khá là ít
Ừ tự nhiên tự tại sao tự nhiên mình nhắc
đến cái bụng cái cái vấn đề đấy Ở đây
bởi vì mình thấy nhớ ở thấy cái bạn khá
hay mà Em xin này mình nghĩ à em xin này
cho Đằng về cá nhân mình thì mình thích
MC ở
Ừ chắc là Lại Văn Sâm mà lại mừng xuân
này à
Ừ thế anh anh Quyền Linh à Nhưng cái
Linh không ở trong cái rung chuông vàng
giống nhau mà không nói tiếng Trung à
cái gì nhỉ Ừ bên này
Lục Lạc Vàng tất cả
và em xin nữa nhưng mà chắc chắn nó
không có mấy MC được dậy khác làm giàu
hay làm từ thiện nha tôi sẽ không không
thích mà mci dụ dỗ người khác đi làm từ
thiện ở đây là lại cái đấy ra mà thôi
nhanh nhạy cảm nhưng vẫn chính trị nhạy
cảm Tôi không nhắc nữa Nhưng mấy ông
thầy ơi ở ra đôi khi nó sẽ cũng dùng từ
lừa gà đúng đấy à
ừ ừ
Ừ thì ạ mục tiêu dạy của mình ấy mình
mình vừa rồi nói qua cái bài này để nó
có liên quan đến mục tiêu và thực ra mục
tiêu dạy của mình khác mục tiêu dạy của
khá nhiều thầy cô
không biết mình nói các bạn chưa đủ tiêu
dậy của mình thì luôn là để cho cho các
bạn
cảm thấy cái ngành này nó không thấy khó
khó như là các bạn mỹ đứng ở chuyện sau
thì đúng là nó xúc à nếu mà nếu mà để
học hoa để biết để biết thôi về vận dụng
được nó đấy hiểu được công nghệ thông
tin là cái gì thì nó không phải khó nó
không phải cái gì đó phải là một ông
được gì mong hòa sách thì mới học được
công nghệ thông tin
khi mở các bạn sẽ khi mà học xong anh
học xong cái khóa này của mình nghĩ hi
vọng là thứ nhất các bạn hiểu được cái
website hoạt động nhà hiểu được bất kỳ
ứng dụng là hoạt động như thế nào nó cơ
chế như là bằng trước cho nên nó là cái
thứ gì đó hào nhoáng nhưng thực ra không
quan trọng Quan trọng là phải đằng sau
cái bác em là xử lý như thế nào mình sẽ
có thể chửi và những cái thằng mà làm
cái ứng dụng rất là đều
tất cả ứng dụng bây rồi Các bạn đang
dùng có thể hàng tỷ người dùng cho nữa
nó vẫn có cái đều của nó mình hơn ăn
chửi nó bởi vì mình đã hiểu được à Làm
cái này như thế nào Tại sao mày không
làm đúng họ rất nhiều lý do
và thủ tiêu của mình không phải dậy các
bạn khiến các bạn tốt lên hà theo cái
ngành này
à mà để các bạn hiểu hơn các bạn có thêm
cái sự lựa chọn nữa nếu mà các bạn đang
đang kiểu không biết được chọn ngành nào
thì đây ở thêm một cái lựa chọn các bạn
về nó miễn phí mà thử duy nhất tốn kém ở
đây là các bạn tốn thời gian và tốn công
suất để học thôi nghĩ rằng nó con miễn
phí so với nhờ cái khác đối ngoại
ờ ờ
I và mục tiêu dạy nữa của mình thì vẫn
là
chắc là để chia sẻ kiến thức các bạn
thôi chứ không phải mục tiêu dạy của
mình đó là nhiều người biết đến kiếm
được tiền
được rất nhiều trò giỏi thật chứa được
các bạn kiểu kiểu trả ơn hai cái gì gió
là không tiêu dậy của mình
Vì thế nên là ở
Xin chào mình sẽ dậy khác so với Nhờ
thầy cô khác và kỳ vọng của mình Hi vọng
của mình cũng sẽ khác sau bao nhiêu thầy
cô khác nhiều người có khác sẽ thất vọng
thì các bạn chưa giỏi
chỉ còn mình thất vọng khi mà các bạn
nào thì các bạn bỏ cuộc giữa nửa chừng
khi mà mình thấy các bạn có tố chất nhờ
các bạn lại lại à
áo kiểu các bạn là sợ thay đổi
khi con người đối với mình thì con người
phải nên quen với việc là ở thay đổi
thấy không không nên là kiểu dạng là
kiểu
dạng ngày
a Pokemon kiểu dạng là quen được cái gì
đó rồi lại ngại kiểu
ngại học cái thứ gì ở mới
ngại bước ra khỏi vùng an toàn vân vân
vân
em có bạn vừa hỏi về cái liên quan việc
mình mất em cún
à thực ra thì cái này chả vẫn đang trong
15 năm sự thì mình sẽ tâm sự dài hơn một
tí về cái chuyện này Thứ nhất là tại sao
mình bị
bị mất em cún bởi vì là hôm đấy là mình
mình có ra ngoài mình à
ạ sau đó đi mình kiểu Nhờ mẹ cho nó ăn
nhưng mà có vẻ mẹ lại lỡ 11 cậu nó chạy
mất hôm đấy thì được là mình cả tính
trường hợp về việc là nó có thể chạy ra
ngoài
Ừ mình cũng định thích nó nhưng mà thôi
Mình nghĩ à không nên ông thích nó cho
nó chạy ngang qua trong nhà mình cho
thoải mái mình lại khóa cửa Khóa cẩn
thận rồi nha mẹ mẹ đến mẹ mày mở cửa ra
nên thành ra không tí như trường hợp đây
ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mình đã nghĩ khá nhiều trường
hợp rồi Không biết các bạn như thế nào
nhưng mà mình mình đã từng đọc một cái
đó là người thông minh người cẩn thận vì
thì sẽ luôn tính hết mọi trường hợp và
trình viên đô thị thế sẽ luôn tính hát
mọi trường hợp cả Trường hợp xấu nhất
đến trường là tốt nhất Trường hợp xấu
nhất là mình tự nghĩ việc bị mất hai cái
gì đó rồi nên là mình cũng nghĩ việc
giải quyết vấn đề như thế nào đó làm
được hết mọi khả năng của mình để sao
cho mình không ân hận đấy con đường của
mình ở thế nghĩa là
khi bị mất em đấy đứng như là mình sẽ
đăng lên mọi
bọn nhóm có thể này đã ngày rồi chia sẻ
nhiều Cái thứ như ngoài treo theo mình
thì mình thì ví dụ là người bắt về bát
mất em đấy Chắc à không không hẳn là
Trộm chó Trộm chó gần nhà mình thì ít và
bị mất nhanh như thế thì chắc là có thể
hàng xóm bắt đấy à mình mình chú tâm vào
giải ừ ừ A và
mình cũng qua mấy cái chỗ bán chó về mà
đưa tờ rơi người ta để người ta thấy có
thể liên lạc
mà dẫn cả còn thêm một tí cái vụ nhanh
quan vụ hôm qua hôm qua thì thì mình gặp
lừa đảo mình tin là lừa đảo ờ
dự báo là kiểu họ có đầu tiên thì buổi
trưa mình có một người đàn ông trung
niên thì vậy Gọi cho mình câu đầu tiên
hỏi là muốn chuộc không
có sờ cởi hãy nói mày muốn chua không
đấy mình biết được là tống tiền thôi
tống tiền kiểu gì mà lấy chó thì mình
cũng nghĩ trường hợp với rồi thì mình
đầu tiên thì họ bạn ạ à Nhà ấy bảo 3
triệu cho mình tự nhiên là lúc đấy mình
sẽ biến thành một hàng này tôi nói của
giọng kiểu trí thức sinh viên trẻ con
kiểu Dạ cháu à Cháu con là sinh viên chỉ
có thể giảm bớt cho hai triệu không có
thứ thì họ đỡ như họ Đông Mỹ
ạ Sau đó gì à
à
mình mình à
Ừ mình qua đấy qua cái địa chỉ người ta
lúc đầu thì mình định tính ở mình sẽ dụ
thêm một ai đó qua đi cùng nhưng mà hôm
qua có bạn mình cũng được nên thực à Nếu
mà trong trường hợp mà gặp người ta như
thế để bạn tránh bị gì đó và làm bìa kể
cả cho dù bạn trưởng thành nam nữa nhưng
mà mặt mình khi non choẹt tất cả mình bé
hơn người ra đấy đãi nên dùng máy lớn
hay gì ơi cùng
là tôi tôi không khuyến khích cái việc
là trả tiền cho mày cái kiểu Trộm chó
hay cái gì đó Tớ tin đấy trộm chó chứ
không phải là kiểu người ta Nhặt hộ được
mình nói cái giọng nó khắc khác khác
hoàn toàn nhận
Ừ nhưng mà đương nhiên là đôi khi mình
muốn cho xong chuyện bởi vì mình đã biết
cái vụ mà bạn mình bị mất như thế nó
tống tiền 14 triệu nó không trả thằng
kia nó cứ lấy xong rồi mà cho đi mổ luôn
nói chuyện nó khá là buồn
ông không kiện công an được về làm gì
xác nhận để đón cháu của ông
Ừ mẹ thôi Đang ở chấp nhận
nói chung và mình đền đấy thì nó không
có đấy
nó gọi mình phải gọi nó mới của nóng trả
lời xong rồi nó nó bảo là chuyển khoản
em về chuyển khoản cho cho nó rồi nó sẽ
gửi cho địa chỉ
Anh tên lửa đến đây mình biết rồi cả
ngày Có thể lừa đảo chắc rồi
gửi xong có khi mất mất tích thế này là
mình cứ bảo nó là ở gửi địa chỉ trước
của mình có thể gửi tiền cho cái bác bán
nước ở cạnh đấy nó thể đến lấy hoặc là ý
nghĩa là nó phải trả cho mình về con chó
mình
quan điểm quan điểm này nhá mình nó có
điểm mình nhé đó Nếu thực sự họ con chó
của mình thì thực ra là họ cần mình họ
cũng cần mình Họ thân tiền của mình bởi
vì Ê con chó phốc bình thường của mình
thì giá nó chỉ một đến mười triệu rưỡi
mà lên được hai triệu là quá là hồi so
với họ rồi Nếu mà họ không bán cho mình
Họ bán người khác
Vì thế nên là họ sẽ cấm tiền của mình
nếu họ đang cầm chó mình còn đây ông ấy
nói với cậu ông ấy không tải con chó
mình thôi cứ bờ mày không trả tao bán
được khác cút hãy con thứ em mình biết
thừa nó lừa đảo theo kiểu dạng không cần
cho mình nói chị đòi tiền mình thấy
soi mình mình mình thì bảo nó tại sao nó
trả lời thế xong mình giữ máy cho nó
không liên lạc nữa mình biết chắc chắn
là nó không cần được cho mình nên nó
cũng chẳng vòng thêm được nữa
thế thôi em mình lại tiếp tục kiểu đi
tìm chó chứ mình không bận tâm nó nữa
Không biết các bạn nghĩ thế nào nhưng mà
theo mình thấy em một sự điều đó và tôi
tin là nhiều ông ở đây nếu mà chưa từng
gặp mấy trường hợp đấy biết đâu Gửi cho
họ thì thì mất thêm tiền không ạ
à à
anh không chết cho nó sẽ dùng với cái
xin rác thôi ông vẫn còn tin nó rung một
số thật để gọi cho mà không nói chuyện
đấy
à à
sự kiện kiện sao được em không không
không Cái vụ lừa tiền bạn bạn anh thì
không phải lừa tiền bạn anh là gặp trực
tiếp Nó nó có chó của nó cơ tấm tiện 14
triệu con chó đứng ngại mà họ mang chó
đi thật cơ nhưng nhưng mà
Ê thằng này nó Nó kiểu nó thấy đắt bảo
nó không muốn trả
Thế thì thằng kia nó nó không không trả
nữa nó cho đi xử luôn
vì thế mà
gửi thằng kia con chó nó có cho nó tiền
con chó nhà tôi con chó cũng kiểu cho
phát huy được ra nói khá rẻ nên thực ra
là người ta không tống tiền nhiều
Ừ nhưng mà Đấy trong trường hợp Giả sử
có người nào tốt người tốt đấy mà là đứa
cháu của ông ấy Họ sẽ liên hệ và họ
không đòi tiền của đấy tù tao mong đưa
họ vào nhiều Đưa nhận thường Đôi khi họ
không thấy đâu Họ sẽ kiểu khác Con để
tống tiền tượng trộm chó là cửa khác và
tống tiền lừa đảo nó kiểu khác nữa đúng
không ạ mẹ không phải phân biệt mấy cái
khái niệm đấy
và tôi tin ở Hôm qua tôi đã Hôm qua tôi
khát tình khi mà xử lý mái trường hợp
như thế
nếu mà mày ông rơi vào trường hợp mà giờ
xương mất cho kiểu ông khá yêu thương nó
có người báo thì bao nhiêu tiền cũng đưa
thì đừng nói việc ông ngồi mà cả như tôi
sao lại kiểu không trả tiền nó nó ví dụ
ở đền hình à chị nhà này chị nhà vẫn còn
đang bảo là kiểu Nhỡ đâu nó cầm chó thật
của mình khi khám
Ừ không sao điều đấy cứ tỉ lệ để nó cầm
nhỏ mình cần nhiều không
à Bà ờ tiện thể về vụ đấy mình cũng tình
những trường hợp với việc à là sổ là còi
bắt mất như thế này
khi mà họ không đem bán thì chắc là họ
đang nuôi đúng không Thì thôi thì
Ừ nếu đó là sự Họ đang nuôi thì chắc
mình mình lại phải nghĩ lạc quan là chắc
là hết duyên Hơi gì đó và chó mình đi ra
cũng được nuôi người khác thì chắc vẫn
tốt Mình chỉ Trường hợp xấu nhưng tệ
nhất là nó bị làm sao thôi còn nếu mà
người khác nuôi không sao còn bán thì
chắc là bây giờ khó thể có con chó của
tôi 6 tháng tuổi rồi không biết có bán
được không cơ trong nó cũng bị ảnh hưởng
Ừ nếu mà bán thì thì tôi đã gửi phát tờ
rơi các tới rồi hoàn toàn họ thì bán lại
cho tôi sẽ tàn giá nó sẽ hơi hơn so việc
nó đi bán không người khác vẫn có nghĩa
cái trường hợp bán thì lại trường hợp
đang không xảy ra nữa sửa trường hợp là
có người nó bắt nhận nuôi thôi Bởi vì mẹ
tôi chỉ tôi Tôi không biết vụ vụ này nhớ
mẹ tôi bảo là sau Tết thì ai mà nhặt
được con chó thì họ coi để điềm may à
mình cho hơi khó
Ừ Tôi tin là vài ông cuống này sẽ chuyển
tiền thật đấy
học biệt gấu chị nhà thôi này còn con
gái thì thường ai kiểu
tình cảm lần đi gửi lý trí trong lúc đấy
rồi khóc lóc đòi chuyện
ừ ừ
anh không những điện lúc đấy không phải
tình Ông ấy tính tất cả trường hợp đi
ông phải biết được là nó cần mình hay
mình cần nó nếu ngọn đôi bên cùng có lợi
thôi
a tiếp theo về cái vụ à
Ừ ừ đúng rồi mình biết được cái vụ làm
Sim gắn định vị rồi Nhưng thực sự ấy cái
mình cũng nghĩ rằng nó lấy Và cũng nghĩ
lại một tí thứ nhất là mình không Mình
mình có vòng cổ nó cơ nhưng mà mình
không đeo nó của việc nó đang ở trong
nhà mà mình đưa mỗi khi nó ở trong nhà
với mình thì nó sẽ không dám chạy đi đâu
cả nhưng mình không tính ơi trường hợp
là làm mẹ mình qua rồi mở cổng Để nó
chạy như thế nó chạy tra chào nó chạy
hôm đấy nó chạy đi tìm mình hôm nay mình
không mọi nhà cho nó sẽ thì mình hở mình
không tính chưa hợp đấy hội đen
và thực ra thì Nếu giả sử mà có gắn
thiết bị như thế được ra nó chỉ cùng mà
định vị được lần cuối thôi bởi vì họ Ừ
nó nói trộm trộm của mình kiểu gì nói
sẵn tháo hết mọi thứ của mình ra ông
không định vị được đâu đó ngọn cái này
chắc là chỉ định vị được cái chỗ gần
nhất gần nhất là nó chạy đến hay gì đó
thôi
Ừ kệ Thực ra nó hơi khó
khỏi không ạ
ừ ừ
à à Còn cái vụ mình nói của nhé Đây vụ à
thực ra cái vụ mất tài khoản Facebook
này mình từng Suýt mất cái tài khoản
Facebook hiện đại của mình nó hơi bị
chới chứ không đồng ý đó Là mình từng
bang ở trên cái chính cái blog của mình
cái blog mà mình nhờ cái Cái bài đầu
tiên thì vậy
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Cái bài đầu tiên
à mình mình đăng về cái việc bảo mật
Facebook nó nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi Mình đang về việc bảo mật
Facebook sau đó thì do chính mình bị bị
mất nick Face hơi buồn cười
thì tại sao bệnh viện mất nick Face thì
mình có nghĩ hai trường hợp gần đây có
gì xảy ra một lần mình dùng wi-fi chùa
wi-fi công cộng bởi vì hôm đấy mình đi
bệnh viện mình dùng cái phạm những cái
wi-fi không biết được nó khó khiến cho
bị lộ cô kia tao cái gì không ra wi-fi
chùa wi-fi công cộng khá nguy hiểm
Thứ hai là
mình đã từng đăng nhập ở máy ở quán net
Mình nghĩ là nếu mà đăng nhập vào máy
quán net thì nó có thể xảy ra tình huống
cái việc là
nó cắm cái USB để mà khi lốp keyloggers
nghĩa
lưu lại toàn bộ những cái gì Ông gọi lên
bàn phím là thứ còn cái điểm chết nữa
của mình lần đấy là mình có lưu lại à
Như lại trình duyệt ở trên trên trên máy
ở quán net bởi vì a với bởi vì bình
thường hay đến đấy mình ngồi chơi nhà
mình kẹo cứ mỗi lần phải mình có mở Bảo
Ừ nhưng mà Chính vì nó bảo mày hãy mở
lớp đôi khi ở phía nó Bình lười quá mình
có phải lôi điện thoại ra để ngồi nhập
mã lần đấy mình nhắn lưu trình duyệt
nhưng chắc là chính vì Lưu chị Lưu trình
dược xong rồi tôi có đưa nhà tôi dùng
thì ẩn danh là tôi đang xuất ra thử rồi
nhưng mà vì lưu trình duyệt nghĩa lưu
lại cứ điện chỉ ra lưu Nếu mếu cũng
không biết về cái quán net nó hoạt động
như thế nào thì thực ra khi tôi tôi ở
tôi lưu trình duyệt ở trên máy máy một
ngon nhưng mà đến cả máy 273 tôi mở lên
thì hội Không Cần Phải mở mật khẩu hai
lớp nữa để làm chuyện đó lưu lại trình
duyệt được trên mọi máy ở quán net bởi
vì Tại sao lại như thế bởi vì tất cả các
máy của nét Thực ra nó cái cây của nó
không có tác dụng là là một máy riêng mà
nó đều nối đến một con máy chủ của quả
nét
Ừ thì đang bận quá này có thể có nhiều
máy chỗ nhưng mà nó không hiểu gì tôi
không nghĩ làm gì à là tất cả các máy
còn nét nó đều cho ta nối đến một thằng
Ngân hàng ra khi mà ông ấy lưu lưu trình
duyệt trên một ngoái Thực ra là nó trên
mọi ngoài Ông không cần phải đăng nhập
lại
ông không phải nhập lại mã mật khẩu hai
lớp đấy thế nên là một khi mà tôi bị lộ
cái mật khẩu của Facebook của tôi nó
hoàn toàn để đăng nhập lại vào cái tài
khoản của tôi trên bất kỳ máy nào ở trên
bàn ép đấy à
đi
đái thế thế nên là thế nên là tôi Tôi
nghĩ là có thể trường hợp thứ 2 có gì
xảy ra thì ăn Tôi bị bị thơ ca thì thằng
ấy nó không thể đăng nó nó nó không thể
đăng nó đăng xuất đồng Mọi sẽ bị rồi nó
đổi email của tôi rồi đâu à Ê hồi đấy
như nó đổi mật khẩu chưa nhờ nhờ đó là
mật khẩu rồi
Ừ nhưng mà ờ và hồi đấy tự nhiên thằng
Facebook nó con bị về vấn đề đó là tôi
có dùng tôi mở cái tính năng là
là người người thân 3 trong 5 người tin
cậy của mình có thể mở lại mình nick Thế
thì cái tính năng đấy của thằng Facebook
Hồi đấy còn bị lỗi cơ thì ra là kiểu tôi
gần như không có cách nào lấy nick chỉ
có mỗi cái việc có một cái giữa hai này
nữa đó là nó năng rút khỏi mọi Thiết bị
ở đúng không Nhưng cái tay nhưng mà do
là điện thoại tôi vẫn còn lưu lại cái kể
tài khoản đấy
ý nghĩa là không cần phải nhập mật khẩu
vẫn có thể và lại được nên thành ra là
vẫn bấm thì vẫn vào nick nick trong
trường hợp đấy nó đang bị
ông kiểu bị khóa khóa không hiểu lắm
thằng ấy làm khóa của gì Nghĩa tôi vẫn
tôi vẫn phải cần nhập
mã bảo mật 2 lớp đi làm mà mật hai lớp
nó không về cơ đấy Facebook có làm cho
cực Nói chung à
để sử dụng tính năng gửi hơn à Mấy ông
mò bên cài đặt tới tối khuya là bơ canh
tốt nhất là mấy ông nên mò và trong phần
cài đặt
Ê mấy ông lên nên bảo mật tài khoản bản
thân mình đi mò trong cài đặt nhiều mà
mình dân công nghệ mình không nên ngại
đọc mình cái đấy mình ngồi mò cho mày có
nhiều và nếu không sẽ khám phá khá nhiều
thứ đấy đấy thì
nói chung là tôi đành phải tìm cách bất
đắc dĩ nhất một cách mà thời là không
Anh mong muốn đó đi tìm các nhóm phi cơ
để mà Bởi vì tôi biết là cái thằng hay
đi tội là một hạn chế cơ chế cơ kiểu mấy
thằng tìm cái mẹo để lách ra lách lách
bật đấy
nó không được gọi là hack Bởi vì thực ra
nó không có kiến thức công nghệ thông
tin gì cả chị dùng mấy cái mẹo nó ngồi
mò mò a màu càng nhiều mẹo rồi để cố mà
phá thì cái đấy Mình sẽ không gọi nó là
hacker trẻ thích cờ người cái mẹo vặt
thôi đấy thì
tôi tôi cũng phải đi tìm mấy đâu mà uy
tín lý cho dù là
mình mình đưa tiền người ta mà đúng ạ
sau đó anh Tuấn Lúc đầu anh Tuấn biết vụ
đấy anh tuấn bảo tôi là không nên như
thế anh đấy tôi bị mất một cái nick đây
do anh ấy để tên thật như bây giờ Hồi
trước anh ấy không để tên thật anh ở
nhưng mà do người từng bị mất nick và
anh ấy do mình chưa từng để chân thật và
cũng chưa từng bang ảnh lên nên anh là
không lấy lại được nick
Ừ nhưng mà anh ấy không được nghĩ việc à
Tìm mấy thằng chích cơ bởi vì mấy hạn
chế cơ có thể là sẽ mua khi mà họ lại
lại được nick của anh ấy rồi hoàn toàn
nó cũng có thể vào nick của anh ấy lần
nữa để phá hai cái gì đó đúng hạn thì ra
là nguy hiểm nên là anh ấy sẽ không làm
thế
xe tôi nhỉ thính tôi thì cũng được anh
khuyên à Nó nó chỉ em cách thì thì được
thôi còn mua khi mà nó bảo em cung cấp
cho nó chứng minh thư hai cái gì đó lại
cảm để mà nó lấy lại nick của em và rất
là thôi thế này là tôi cũng phải đi tìm
màu tím ý rồi cũng cho tìm được mùa đông
ông ấy cũng ở trong nhóm kia tin
committee thế này là tôi nghĩ cũng sắp
đi này tôi cũng không tôi inbox anh đợi
cùng thì không phải chỉ tôi cái mẹ là
ngồi ngồi đấy có cái cho bởi vì tôi vừa
nói đó là cái mã cài mã bảo mật 2 lớp
không về máy điện thoại tôi và thằng
thằng kia thằng hacker cái không thể xóa
cái số điện thoại tôi khỏi khỏi nick tôi
được bởi vì nó phải yêu cầu mã xác nhận
gửi máy Nếu không biết rồi đúng không ạ
Thế nên là ông ấy chỉ là tôi có cho tôi
không biết là bây giờ nhăn dụng được đâu
nha Bây giờ mới ông ăn dụng máy ông bị
sao đừng có đòi lại tôi nhá Mà hồi đấy
anh ông ấy chỉ cái trò đó là ngôi Star
cái mã đấy size 20 lần Ừ thì nó sẽ đổi
sang cái spoil dạng khác và tôi thử thế
Đúng thế thật nó nhảy sang loại thịt bôi
khác thì đương nhờ hoàn toàn là tôi làm
được
ngày mai mai như thế
nhưng mà bây giờ thì mình nhớ là gần đây
thì cái vụ mà ba tài khoản tin cậy có
thể hỗ trợ lấy lại được nick bây giờ lại
chạy được rồi Nên là các bạn nên áp dụng
cách đây hơn
Anh
ấy thì lời khuyên tôi vừa kể câu chuyện
đó nó đó là gì đó là kiểu các bạn
là dân công nghệ các bạn cũng nên nghĩ
trường hợp và
tại sao bị như thế
khi mà xảy lỡ xảy ra rồi thì các bạn
phòng chống và xử lí nó như thế nào đúng
ạ
đá banh đá Đồng Văn II
ở đâu rồi dùng cái bảo mật người thân
tin cậy kia nó nguy hiểm có nguy hiểm ở
cái Nếu vì vì chính cái nó có checkpoint
cái đấy nên nó không có chiếc bao người
khác nếu có hiểu không Thằng Facebook
khi mà nó xác nhận lại nick của ông ấy
nó sẽ luôn gợi ý 3 hoặc 4 cái thôi và
Nếu giả sử mà ba bốn cái đấy đều có vấn
đề thì phát gì là nick của ông vứt đóng
ngoặc nên là nên là thằng Nói chung là
thằng Facebook nó ra để mình Các bạn nên
rồi
vì nó rất là điều mang tiền nó tỉnh
người dùng nghe nó vẫn còn những cái
kiểu cháu bị mấy hơn chicle Star nó cả
Chắc là chính vì do là Việt Nam mình bị
chị cơ chế câu mình tin chức ở Việt Nam
phá Đông spam nhiều nên thành ra nó làm
cái cái vụ tính năng bảo mật khá lỏng
lẻo ở Việt Nam nó kệ luôn ấy khẳng định
dùng từ nó kệ luôn bởi vì sao Bởi vì
nước ngoài ấy cái xúc bóp hỗ trợ để mà
lấy lại tài khoản nó tốt hơn ở Việt Nam
rất nhiều Việt Nam mình bị bị rắn span
đến thành ra là kiểu toàn boss trả lời
thôi mà toàn boss để lấy lại nick của
ông và cũng chính vì thế nên boss nó mấy
thằng kia cơ thì kia nó chỉ cần Lách qua
được con boss là lấy lại được lấy nick
của mấy ông thế nên là mấy ông cũng
không nên để lộ thông tin gì đó giống
như tên đầy đủ kèm theo Thông tin cá
nhân chứng minh thư vào nó văn nó nó dễ
lấy mấy của mấy ông ăn ạ
Anh Tuấn nhân nên làm gì ở bảo vệ á thì
như mình nói đấy nó thực ra ở đây mình
mình còn nói qua với cách bỏng
Token à
Cái
Tru Tiên scotty hình như mình nhớ là có
cái liên quan đến bảo vệ đây không không
không
ở đây
chỉ có vài cái ở đây nó
Ồ thông qua ở đây
ở những cái mà các bạn cần nên cài đặt
để mà
chỉnh lại mức độ thì nó có vài cái ở đây
tôi thấy ở khung Hoàn lắm cái này tôi
chưa Mở thông báo email Ok thì sữa này
cái này thì
ai có thể gửi kết bạn với bạn thì mình
đang để là tất cả mọi người đều được
thực ra anh này ra muốn là để cho chỉ có
bạn của bạn bè được thôi Thực ra thì đây
Cái này cốt để chỉ nói về các bạn không
nên kết bạn bừa bãi even công cụ tìm
kiếm và để tìm kiếm được bạn cái này thì
ra Tùy mình thấy không Hà Nội bảo mật
lắm cái này riêng tư hơn
ai và ai có thể bình luận được trên
trang cá nhân của bạn mình cứ để tất cả
mọi người
còn những cái khác của mình thì đang đều
được rồi này ví dụ kiểu phải xem lại
toàn bộ những cái người ta tát mình vần
ẩn đi toàn bộ những cái thông tin này
Anh không dùng thì không bắt à không dây
công nghệ nhưng công nghệ của mình không
phải là cơ bảo mật bằng cách không dùng
các thiết bị gì đó mình mình cách để
chống hack ơi chỉ đơn giản là mình phải
thông minh hoàng hacker mình để mình
phải hiểu biết hơn thằng hacker đấy
à còn đúng là nếu mà ông cảm thấy ông
không hiểu biết hơn bọn nó thì đúng là
ông phải không dùng Ok
hôm nay thì mình sẽ kiểm tra các đồ ăn
các bạn bây giờ đưa 8 giờ không ạ
khi chờ đợi có họ nhé
Ừ thôi có hỏi này không liên quan nó bổ
hôm nay cho đời sau nhé mình sẽ kiểm tra
đồ ăn các bạn đến 9 giờ sau đó thì mình
sẽ
thực tế hướng dẫn các bạn về
viết tài liệu và nói qua quy trình bảo
vệ đoán hay là bây giờ mình nói qua này
trước rồi mình kiểm tra cho các bạn chọn
Ừ tôi thì thấy bây giờ Đang tám với
người có vẻ khá đông nhưng mà tôi không
biết được hả Tí tầm 9 giờ cũng không
biết còn đông hơn hay là vắng hơn cái
mấy ông ga đôi khi cho nó hơi
xe hơi sai sai nhiều lúc đến cuối giờ tự
nhiên thấy mấy ông on đônh thế
Ừ đúng rồi mình sẽ kiểm tra các nhóm
tiếp theo còn cả nhà mới trước thì mình
đánh giá qua rồi đấy ông ạ nhỏ hôm trước
này
anh gà trống chưa mình kiểm tra hơi ít
nhỉ trước mình kiểm tra được đến
chị Linh kiểm tra 8 nhóm hơi lông thì
hơi chậm tiến độ mình thị
cho anh ngắm 11 hôm trước anh nhớ đồ rồi
à
cho con những gà mấy cái nhóm ở dưới này
làm cho nhóm đợt 2 chắc chắn luôn đấy
mình nhớ đấy nó bắt đầu từ 44 nhóm được
ai đâu
à à
bài hát mấy ông muốn thế nào tôi nói quà
với này trước sau đó rồi mới kiểm tra
hai tôi kiểm tra trước rồi mới nói về
mấy cái mấy cái này
tắm 6 rồi tin nhanh vãi
Anh em đâu hết rồi đó là tôi để chế độ
là
anh chat cái hiển thị sáng nay mình nghỉ
Ừ khi nào qua chơi nhé
thì đầu tiên thì hôm nay là ngày 12 đúng
không
bắt được bắt đầu từ tuần sau đi bắt đầu
từ tuần sau mình sẽ mình sẽ cho bảo vệ
Thu
anh ạ
thì mình sẽ ấy mình nghĩ là thế
Ừ đúng nghỉ tuần sau
âm thanh sáo hôm nay mình nói để các bạn
chuẩn bị này thì chắc là
thứ bảy tuần sau mình sẽ cho bảo vệ
thuộc
anh vào ngày 19 chị sẽ có vài nhóm mình
sẽ ra Đun à
thì mình sẽ cho Loan đun bảo vệ thợ luôn
ngày 15 17 mình sẽ kiểm tra nhưng mà bây
giờ mình không kiểm tra cốt lắm nữa mình
sẽ kiểm tra tài liệu các bạn làm bao bọ
PowerPoint mình kiểm tra nhé mình kiểm
tra our rồi Kiểm tra Gốc Các bạn làm như
thế nào rồi các bạn giữ nghiện cái cách
viết vuốt ở như thế nào Đầu tiên các bạn
phải đọc cái đầu tiên này đã để hướng
dẫn làm word đã tôi không biết mấy ông
như nào Nhưng tôi khẳng định nhiều ông
học trong giờ tin học văn phòng mấy ông
ngồi chơi game này ra tôi vẫn sẽ nó qua
lại tất cả những cái này đó làm gì à Nên
cậu chủ phông chữ ở nên thống nhất này
rồi Vâng luôn cái ông mà không phải làm
đúng hết mình cái này nhá
Không dùng 2 dấu cách nhá Tôi tôi tính
mắt cực với nhìn được hai cách này như
thế nào đây ông ghi thỉnh thoảng mấy ông
thừa hai cuộc cách cách để mấy ông không
vào thừa hai đầu cách ngày mấy ông quan
trôn hát ngồi tìm được
ờ ờ
à còn gì nhỉ à
ở thời tiếp theo là ở
chỉ cách viết tài liệu mô hình như thế
này đòi quà cho một loạt các viết tài
liệu Word
ở đầu tiên là tên trường mấy ông để sửa
lại nào tùy mày không thích mình không
để trường mới không được không Tăng cái
cách viết tài liệu này tôi là tôi đang
hướng dẫn và cách viết tài liệu khá là
trung của công nghệ thông tin
sau khi mà kể cả các ông làm ở trường
tôi không biết mấy ông ở trường có được
cái mẫu nào không nhưng mà ở trường tôi
mẫu nhà tôi mới sửa lại cái logo trường
đã tên trường thôi con chủ yếu nó sẽ như
thế này
tên tên kiểu logo có thứ xong rồi Đồ ăn
một đồ ăn hay này tên đề tài gì này Đấy
tên lớp tên nhóm
Ê mấy ông chẳng có tên tên lớp được à
các thành viên này tên thành viên này
tên giảng viên Thì ra mấy ông thể xóa
tên Đoàn Viên lại được cũng mình tôi
nhưng tôi để đây thì làm chị ở mấy ông
hãy áp dụng cho cả sửa máy ông nói học
đại học mà không hiểu gì về sau chẳng
làm có thể áp dụng cả cái cái mẫu này
nữa
tên thành phố này
có phải cái mục lục mày là lễ nhớ nhá
mục lục này là khi các bạn làm word xong
hết từ đầu đến cuối các bạn sẽ ấn vào
việc các bạn thể gõ cho gỗ được cách tạo
mục lục word nó sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn và
mục lục của tạo tự động như nào Tại sao
phải gọi khái niệm tạo mục lục tự động
bởi vì các bạn có thể Click vào cái này
để nhảy đến cái phần đấy và nó sẽ sinh
ra số trang tự động chứ mọi các bạn Nhập
tay cái lại không có chuyện rồi nhập tay
cái đâu được không ạ
Vì sao tự nhiên có người nước ngoài vào
bình luận chứ à
ở đó sau đó thì tiếp theo là phần nào
hệ
thống kê đang sao mà
a
phần mở đầu này các bạn sẽ giới thiệu
giới thiệu qua đề tài qua thôi và có thể
đưa lời cảm ơn cái gì đó đây rồi tâm sự
gì đó ngoại tùy ông chán mấy ông thư ra
mấy ông hoàn toàn thể trao Google việc
là
đồ án công nghệ thông tin đấy thì mới
ông xem tham khảo thì nên là tham khảo
nhé đừng đừng copy giống hệt nhau Tôi
không muốn là mấy ông giống hệt nhau thì
chẳng ai muốn đọc đúng không ạ
tiếp theo là giới thiệu giới thiệu đây
là đưa vấn đề này và cũng lại giới thiệu
chung lại về đoán
sản xuất xứ dự án Lý do Cái quan trọng
là cái để cập lời lý do để mà làm cái dự
án này là sự là bây giờ mới Ông thấy
cũng mấy cái trang web
làm đều quá với Vân á đúng rồi Đợi thì
tôi gửi cái link này cho mấy ông để ông
xem luôn trực tiếp này à
Ừ
đúng rồi Cái này là thường là năm cuối
của đại học làm nhưng mà đối với trường
tôi sự nghề thì bọn tôi phải làm ba cái
đồ án tốt nghiệp như thế này cơ nên là
cái này là năm thứ hai bọn tôi đã làm
rồi
xe tải
ờ ờ
Ơ cái lý Nói chung là cái đoạn này là lý
do để làm cái dự án
à Còn cái đoạn này mới cụ thể xem tạm mô
tả xem lại trước khi có cái dự trước khi
có cái phần mềm mà trước khi có cái
trang web giả sửa xong ghét bà nó bán
cuộn bán giày đi chẳng trước khi có
trong cái bàn dài này thì được hàng họ
các bạn đang làm gì để mà kiểu kinh
doanh họ xử lý Word Excel đưa lại cái gì
đó để mà lưu lại đơn gì đó nếu không
hiểu gì không ạ
xe tải sao bé ông sẽ liệt kê
Lê Thúy liệt kế
ra những điểm yếu của phần mềm hiện đại
hành xử nộm rơm ra nó không thống kê
được vân vân đấy mấy ông Hãy liệt kê hết
ra ở đây
ạ sau đó thì hệ thống đề nghị là ok thì
mày ông liệt kê tất cả điểm yếu trên rồi
Chị thì bây giờ mình cần phải làm cái
phần mềm gì khắc phục những cái niềm yêu
đấy đúng hoặc nó không thủ công nữa nó
tự động tính toán nó tự động gì đó nhập
một phát là nó sẽ ra cái gì đó Gì Gì đó
Nhanh hơn nó Dung nói trên điện thoại và
vân nóng ạ đấy mấy ông phải để kê những
cái đấy tiếp theo nữa là công nghệ tưởng
béo mà dụng thì mấy ông nên nói cụ thể
là mấy ông áp dụng ngôn ngữ gì dụng HTML
gì CS gì Yes with như thế nào ạ Dùng
thêm gj2 Vân Vân không Mấy ông không nên
ghi Ừ cái phần mềm để mà chạy ví dụ phần
mềm như nào ở các ông chạy bằng trình
duyệt Chrome không không đề cập ở đây
mấy ông dùng xem pihalla Gold chạy mà em
không đi cập vào đây để ông ạ Mấy ông
chị ạ Chị ghi vào đây là những công nghệ
những cái thư viện mấy ông áp dụng tại
sao lại không để cậu máy kia phải vì
mình cái kia không để mấy ông nó chạy
thử test ở trên máy mấy ông thì mày ông
dùng mấy cũng không nên đề cập vào máy
ông dùng bằng sắp Reetech 2 tôm Hãy viết
code trong này Cái đấy là phần mềm để
mấy ông cố tỏ ra không phải phần mềm để
khiến cho cái trang web phải được đóng
bọn mày Ông gửi cho tôi tin là kiểu gì
cũng sẽ có ông nhắc Ông mấy ông mắc phải
đấy nên tôi phải nói rõ như thế đấy à a
tiếp theo là phần yêu cầu Phi chức năng
phía chức năng tất cả không phải một cái
tính năng gì cả giống như tôi đề cập rõ
đây nhiều ông không biết là mình không
cần ghi lại toàn bộ tất cả đúng anh cũng
được chúng ta nhưng mà Mấy ông có thể
nói cụ thể hơn là sử là kiểu
thanh tìm kiếm tiện lợi hay cái gì mà
không thử nghĩ thêm cho mấy ông cha cái
cái khái niệm gì Chức năng của trang web
rồi nếu uống thử tham khảo xem mà cái
trang web Up Down nước cái gì mày không
ông Đạo không ạ
à vì ví dụ là
thực ra là mấy trang web của mấy ông
chưa dùng về trên điện thoại đâu ngờ
trang web làm vừa dùng để trên điện
thoại thì ghi ở đây nó sẽ được à
em yêu cầu chức năng
Ở đây Ờ mấy ông sẽ liệt kê ra là những
đối tượng mà sử dụng trang web mấy ông
cái này thì ra Tôi từng nói với ông rồi
mấy ông cũng từng làm một cái vuốt
có cái đoạn này rồi nhưng nó chưa đầy đủ
thôi Đây nghe meo bây giờ Lưu ý Cái quan
trọng nhất mà cái cái quan trọng và
nhiều người Nhầm nhất này đó phân tích
chức nào cái là một cái rất rất dài cái
này là cái
cậu nhà
cái này là cái cầm phải làm trước khi
Cốt
Ẩm Thực ra tôi đang dạy mấy ông ở đang
dậy khi bị ngược một tí
bởi vì a thời gian béo còn chưa biết cốt
nhưng tôi phải dậy Nếu cốt chưa Còn
Chuẩn đấy Chuẩn đấy Đó là mấy ông sẽ
phải làm cái gốc này trước phải phác
thảo phải phác thảo trước
mình cần làm những cái gì mày cũng hình
dòng họ mày không phải liệt kê tất cả
tính năng và tính năng đấy nó là gì phải
làm tình anh lại như thế nào ở trong
Word trước
và sau đó thì cái tài liệu này sẽ là tài
liệu đưa cho các thành viên của nhóm để
thành viên nhóm nhìn vào cái đại lượng
này để làm ra tính năng đấy thì mới ông
sẽ thấy là cái này là cái phải tương đối
khá đầy đủ cái ông cố tính năng nào là
phải có trong cái phần phân tích trước
này nếu không sẽ nhận ra là cái này rất
dài đây tôi tôi có mẫu ngày dưới này
đây tôi thử mẫu ngay dưới này mấy ông sẽ
thấy này
thì dụng mỗi tính năng đăng nhập thôi
mai thì mình đăng nhập vào nhiều người
dùng em mấy ông ôm vào ôm ôm vàng với
ông hoàn toàn thì nói kiểu này còn vài
trường hợp nữa thì nó chỉ có một người
dùng thôi thì thì
ừ ừ
ở trường em chụp cốt được vào trường em
làm thế là sai bởi vì như đã nói chuẩn
là cái tài liệu là phải có trước khi cốt
nên là chuyện là mấy đấy cũng là một cái
mà Mấy ông nhiều ông đã bị sai điểm hả
Mấy ông chụp cả trang web của mấy ông
cho vào tài liệu Thế là rất là sai luôn
vịt rõ ràng là chuẩn lôgic là kể trong
em có trong cá có trước phải tài liệu
hồi trước tài liệu có trước mà tại sao
rồi mấy ông Thu Trang web phải rồi mấy
ông đi trộm web đâu về Ông chụp ảnh đúng
không Không mấy ông phải có tài liệu
trước mấy cái này phải vẫn thích trước
mấy ông ấy được là đều ngoạn cái này thì
ở vì nó rất là dài vì nó rất dài nên là
mình nghĩ à mình sẽ trả
khi cha chỉ cần chỉ cần các bạn làm phân
tích
10 tính năng thôi 10 tỉnh An thôi là mấy
bạn thể phân tích thêm cũng được
Hồi đấy Mình bắt sinh viên mình nhá toàn
bộ tài liệu này bắt buộc là không được
dưới 25 gian nên là mà lẫn cả là mỗi
tính năng này các bạn nên làm họ thường
hay mất một trang rồi các bạn lời khuyên
các bạn nữa đó là các bạn Nếu bạn muốn
sang tính năng mới các bạn lại thêm cái
bảng nữa đúng không các bạn phải dùng
inspect nhá
ở tuổi
inspect ở đây này cân tune into này để
nhảy sang để mà phân tích cái thằng dừa
nha trước mấy ông đừng có kiểu
áo kiểu dặn mà chèn thêm cái bảng ở đây
thì rõ ràng có một ít chữ ở đây xong rồi
nhảy xuống đây mới đi chợ nữa không
không được như thế nhỉ đúng rồi Cái này
chính là Yusuke này cái này là esk này
mấy ông mấy ông cậu quen dùng tiếng Anh
nhưng mà tôi đang muốn để toàn bộ tiếng
Việt thì phẩm nhất tiếng Việt nên nó
trong nó có vẻ các bạn chưa gặp hơi khó
hiểu đi
nhưng mà Mấy ông nói chung là toàn bộ
cốt của người ông hiện đại mà ông có
được rồi đúng không chỉ trang web mềm
chạy được rồi đúng không Thì mới ông sẽ
phải phân tích lại ra đây thì phân tích
ở nhà thì nhớ là các tác nhân mà ông
hình dung được rồi đó là ai ai làm được
cái tính năng này ai sử dụng một tính
năng này mô tả
anh ở đây nhiều người khó bị hơi bị nhầm
với cái việc mô tả mô tả đây sẽ là mô tả
cái tính năng này cho người ấy không
phải dân công nghệ đọc có thể hiểu được
tính năng này nó là gì bởi vì sao tên
tính năng này đôi khi nó sẽ rất là khó
hiểu ra sự nhé Ở
anh nghe nhạc
ừ ừ
Anh tên lính anh đôi khi ở các bạn sẽ
thì tắt dùm tí sẽ là gì À ừ
A giỏ hàng à
Nghe giọng hát ở kiểu kiểu ngay nhưng mà
mô tả tính anh thì ra nó là
sự thay đổi
số lượng sản phẩm trong giỏ hàng hiệu ở
nhà nó sẽ dài hơn cái này phù hợp cho
việc là ghi cụ thể cụ thể hơn sau một
cái tên này thường là như thế thường mày
như thế còn nếu là tên tính năng các bạn
ở ghi rõ rồi thì các bạn mô tả lại không
hẳn quan trọng lắm tiếp theo phân kích
hoạt đây
cái kích hoạt này đầu vào này nhiều
người sẽ đỡ bị nhầm một tí cái hoàn này
là cái thường liên quan đến việc à Cái
click chuột các bạn sẽ click nó nhịn vào
đâu Nó được kích hoạt khi nào
Có khi nào nói chung cái này tiếng Anh ở
dễ hiểu hơn việc nó nghe hơi thông thì
Nhưng nói chung nhà liên quan đến việc
là nó cái họa nó nó chạy khi nào mày họ
khi các bạn bấm vào đâu này Đấy bấm vào
nút nào ở đâu này đúng ạ đầu vào lại
không liên quan đến cờ thứ mà các bạn đã
bấm mà đầu vào nó lại liên quan đến việc
là cái gì các bạn Nhập vào bàn phím
ngoại tại sao mình phải đề cập vụ đấy Ở
đây bởi vì nó nếu mà giả sử các bạn liên
quan việc và xóa sản phẩm là sự ngay thì
kích hoạt là khi bấm vào nút xóa
cạnh sản phẩm được ạ và sửa ngay nhá Thì
cái đầu vào các bạn sẽ nghĩ là đầu vào
đây sẽ làm là mã sản phẩm đó ông ạ ạ Ừ
đúng ạ
ở những cái này Thực ra là đôi khi nó
không đúng một vì rõ ràng đầu vào là
nhập vào từ bàn phím cơ
mình nó hơi khó hiểu tí nhỉ à
Ừ nếu mà nhưng mà ý của mình đầu vào đây
nó sẽ là những cái thông tin mình truyền
vào bao gồm và việc lấy thông tin gì đến
hạnh địa chỉ qua cả những cách hướng
nhập từ bàn phím về nó đầu bạc đấy
ý nghĩa đôi khi ở các bạn sẽ không bị
nhầm cái vụ đầu vào với cái kích hoạt
mày
chắc là mình sẽ cần một cái á ở nhóm
hung thứ ba nhóm nào làm rồi thì sẽ chữa
cho nó đấy để các bạn dễ hình dung hơn
với cái vụ này còn cái phần phân tích
này cũng nhận của mình nó hơi bị thì
uống một tí hồi đấy là mình làm chỉ mang
tính chất tương đối thôi chúng mình làm
hết thì sinh viên có hết của mình nên là
mình mới chỉ làm tương đối này thôi
trình tự xử lý này thì là các bạn
các bạn liền Liệt kê lại kiểu gần như
cốt các bạn có cái gì Các bạn chị viết
lại thành văn xuôi theo dạng sau các bạn
ghi ở trong này thôi đúng thì sẽ như nào
say như nào đấy có bạn ra đọc qua cái
này hiểu mà đầu ra là cái các bạn sẽ
hiển thị hiển thị thành công hay thất
bại Sẽ như nào lưu ý ở đây là đây
mình ghi mình nghĩ ở trong cũng tương
đối rồi hôm đấy có ai hỏi thì cha mình
sẽ lại thấy thêm nhé anh
nói chung mà buổi hôm sau bắt đầu từ
buổi hôm nay tôi sẽ yêu cầu mấy ông làm
để vuốt này mày không sẽ thấy tốn thời
gian làm word khá là nhiều đấy khá là
nhiều luôn ấy
tiếp theo phần thiết kế hệ thống này các
bạn sẽ có xô quan hệ thực thể thì cái mà
mình từng từng bảo các bạn làm rồi Các
bạn chỉ cần chèn ấy mạnh trong ai sơ đồ
cơ sở liệu thì cài á sao đâu có sợ liệu
này ngoài việc các bạn cho em cái ngày
này bởi vì cái ảnh này
thường tôi sẽ yêu cầu mấy ông có phải
làm thêm cả cái bàn nữa Tại sao bởi vì
cái ảnh này đôi khi nó nó bị
kiểu nhiều ông làm mười mấy cái bảng ạ
Cái ảnh sẽ rất là bé rửa khó là nhìn như
là mấy ông vẫn phải làm thêm cái bảo này
hòa thượng chứa nhiều ông sẽ vì là mười
mấy ở Thuận chí về sau miếu làm trang
web mà có thể liên quan hay mấy ba mấy
cái vàng miếng sẽ phải chia nhỏ cái ảnh
ngoài ra hàng dẫn ừ anh hãy ra cách để
xem chi tiết nhất thì mấy ông vẫn phải
cần cái bàn này đúng ạ và mấy ông phải
liệt kê rõ như này nữa
Ồ thông tin là mấy ông sẽ cảm thấy rất
mất công thì làm tất cả đúng ai đấy
Ừ nhưng mày ông bắt buộc à chuẩn khi mà
làm cái dự án là có mấy ông phải có đầy
đủ toàn bộ tài liệu như thế này để làm
ra với người ta hình người ta đọc qua
cái tài liệu này người ta hình dung được
chi tiết là cái trang web của ông nó như
thế nào Nếu không vì ông ạ là kiểu mấy
ông phân tích chứ Kể như thế nào họ dược
họ duyệt thì mày ông ấy bắt đầu bắt tay
vào làm Chẳng qua bây giờ mấy ông đang
bị Hơi bị ngược với mấy ông làm từ trang
web trước mà 15 tài liệu Chứ thật ra mấy
ông chuẩn phải làm tài liệu này đã Chồng
béo mới làm trang web thậm chí khi mấy
ông làm trang web không có vấn đề gì đó
Mẹ không phải về sửa tài liệu cơ nhưng
mà thường là ít ai quay lại sửa tài liệu
sơ đồ trang web Cái này tiếng Anh nó là
sai mát đấy được à Tức là khi mà vào
trang web của ông thì tôi có thể đi để
đến được những đâu cũng mát và bản đồ mà
không ạ nữa tôi thì đi đến những ngóc
ngách nào tôi bấm vào đâu để đi đến đâu
tiếp ảnh bìa
Ừ đúng rồi bạn của khô vừa hỏi một câu
rất là đúng mà rất hay đó là
đúng đoán hay các bạn phải làm tài liệu
này trước khi các bạn Cốt Đây không phải
là đồ ăn hay các bạn làm ngược như thế
này nữa đâu Bây giờ tôi đang dạy mấy ông
cốt để mà miệng biết Cốt và dạy mày ông
cách làm thế liệu và đón hay thị thứ
nhất ở các bạn phải làm tại niệm này
trước tôi duyệt đã thì mới ông ấy được
phép cốt thứ hai nữa đó là
mì ông
Ê mấy ông phải ở đang nói thì quên
Anh ở đại khái như thế giới tự nhiên
đang định nói gì quân sự mà
đúng còn mấy ông sẽ phải lại đúng Mọi
thứ hai đó là tôi sẽ không hướng dẫn mấy
ông làm tài liệu nữa thì đến đoạn 2
bình luận hay là các bạn sẽ phải tự lực
khá nhiều Tôi Chị kể cả hướng dẫn cốc
thì Tộ chạy hướng dẫn một cách tương đối
cơ bản tôi sẽ không hướng dẫn nâng cao
mấy không có dẫn trên rau
cho đến kia có bạn Làm gần xong rồi tôi
bắt đầu hướng dẫn chuyên sâu và nâng cao
tôi sẽ không hướng dẫn các bạn đi đường
tắt trước tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn mấy
cái kiểu hàm của Lara chẳng hạn cũng
chưa hàm cơ bản thôi không dùng mới giới
hạn chuyên sâu của nó à
A và tài liệu này là mấy không phải nhớ
khách làm tài liệu từ đoán một chứ tao
không hướng dẫn mấy ông ạ Làm lại tài
liệu và chỉ chữa rong mấy ông nội chữa
khác với việc và hướng dẫn nhá ngoặc Thế
là mấy ông sẽ phải phải làm ngon ngay từ
bây giờ đi
ở trong đồn hai chị tôi khẳng định khá
khổ đoán một thì còn dễ hộ lý luận hay
nó khắc nghiệt Đấy lý do mà những cái
bạn ở trưởng tôi khi mà làm xong đón hay
như tôi đã hứa mèo như tôi vừa đó mấy
ông làm xong đồ ăn hay ở khóa khóa sau
tôi là mấy ông hoàn toàn hệ đi làm được
Vì chắc chắn là mấy ông làm ngon hơn rất
nhiều ông đi làm rồi mày không đi làm
rồi Mấy ông không biết tài liệu này là
cái gì luôn có khẳng định anh nhá
đồ ăn hay của tôi sẽ khác Em Rất Nhiều
Anh
Tuấn hay Ok chứ
MBC và cụ thể nó phấn Wars II Ừ tôi dạy
cá Oppa và Melissa để mà để sang Trung
Quốc mà
à Còn nếu mày ông không dùng level thì
cũng được thôi mấy ông nhảy sang ngôn
ngữ khác cũng được không sao và
nhờ đăng kí khi nào à Chắc là khi mà bảo
vệ xong đón bột mà thì tôi sẽ bắt đầu mở
con đăng ký cho đồ ăn 2a
à à
sau khi làm về cái mới thì làm tài liệu
trước hay học cái kia trước thì mình
mình đang dậy theo cửa trường nghề và
ngọt kẹo dậy ngược cái nghĩa là mình sẽ
học cái kia trước phải mang hiểu và cũng
kiểu thích Thu nó đã rồi mơ làm thời
liệu Bởi vì thực ra là mình chưa biết gì
mình khó mà làm được tài liệu mà không
thì mình sẽ phải phải mình phải học cốt
á mình phải thực hành đã Sau đó mình sẽ
viết lý thuyết Hãy kể
Ê mấy ông vẫn đang hào hứng đón Hay nhỉ
nói chung à bảo vệ xong đi tuần giao
mình mình đang hi vọng đó tuần sau ngày
19 sẽ bảo vệ hiểu được bảo vệ 19 20 22
này chẳng hạn thế nó về sau sau những
cái bảo vệ thử đấy mình xem mà cả nhóm
thực sự ổn chưa Vân rồi mình sẽ chốt
lịch bảo vệ thật lúc đấy sẽ có hàng có
người chấm của mình nữa có vài thầy sẽ
tham dự và vài ạ tài thậm chí à mình sẽ
gạt vài bên tuyển dụng về để có thể tham
dự Đà Nẵng đấy để mà từ đó xem như nào
sợ
và sau đó thì mình mới bắt đầu tính tiếp
là đồ ăn hay sẽ nên như thế nào Cần phải
rút kinh nghiệm gì
An đăng ký đầu ăn hay không yêu cầu các
bạn phải từng làm đồ bán một Các bạn cứ
thoải mái thôi
không nhưng mà nhưng mà có bạn cũng nên
phải biết biết qua những cái mà đã làm ở
đón một cái dỗ cái tài liệu này hay quy
trình bảo vệ là bảo vệ gì đó vì đón Hay
là gần như ở mình sẽ để các bạn tự lực
nhiều hơn đồ ăn hay mình sẽ cố cố hết
sức
dự án đoán hay mày có hát rồi á Không
nghĩa đồn hài chắc chắn chắc chắn là sẽ
có nhà Tuyển dụng đồ ăn hay sẽ là nó sẽ
kiểu sẽ có nhiều người tham dự hơn của
đoán mô thì tôi chưa biết được Nói chung
là đón một thì thôi cứ 50 50 với các bạn
thôi vì vì nếu mà thấy bảo vệ thử mà đã
rất là ổn rất nhiều người chuyển vọng
thì tối dạ cho người trong người xem
cùng còn nếu đoàn bảo vệ Hử thấy tệ quá
thì thảm hại ạ tôi mời mấy người kia vào
xem mấy người mấy người
thế đó mấy người đấy không biết mấy ông
đã học đang trình như nào Mày không hiểu
không bên có thể là kiểu 15 non thì
đương nhiên mày ông đang thế nhưng mấy
hạnh Mấy người tuyển dụng có biết được
đâu đúng không
nói cho người đấy tôi cần nhá gần một
thì sẽ đến tôi đang cần nhắc rất nhiều
cái Con dù lớn hay tôi khẳng định là một
khi nếu không đi bảo vệ đoán hài sáng
được ngon nghệ rồi nên là tôi sẽ phải
sự cố cố tạo cơ hội việc làm mà bé uống
hết sức rồi đấy
từ tài liệu
đề tài liệu này là gộp chung ấy tài liệu
đồ án này là cả hai không phải là có
tách khách hàng riêng ăn Min Dương nhau
thế nên là mấy ông Khi mà một nhóm ông
hai người mấy ông khỏe phải giúp nhau
làm tài liệu này chứ không phải một ông
làm đâu
Ừ đấy thì cái vụ sơ đồ trang web này tôi
đang nói dở ấy thì đó là ông khi phải
trang web này thì ông sẽ
bấm vào ví dụ là Sửa bấm vào sản phẩm
cho tất cả sản phẩm để xem sản phẩm 12
này hay Bấm vào đăng nhập thì mấy ông
mới có thể đặt hàng được vân vân này
xong rồi cái cái cái sơ đồ trang web này
có 2 cái nhá là một cái là menu của
Admin và một cái mới đủ khách hàng đây
là mấy ngủ khách hàng nếu ngọn có mấy
new admin thì sao thì nó sẽ ví dụ đăng
nhập nó sẽ rẽ hai hướng một cái amin thì
ông nọ ông trò nó đi được đến những đâu
và Super admin thì ông sẽ đi đến những
đâu được chưa ạ Ở bên này thì ra à Nó
cũng tương tự ở bên này sẽ Đây là toàn
bộ này thì gần như chung chung của khách
chưa nông nghiệp còn thấy là đã làm ngập
thì nó sẽ nhảy xong rồi đăng nhập này
xong nhảy xuống dưới nữa đăng xuất này
xong rồi đặt hàng vân vân nữa này đúng
không ạ
à à
Ừ cái này thử cái là do là tôi đang cố
làm nó hơi bị mẫu một tí để mấy ông phải
tự nghĩ nhiều hơn chứ tôi mà cứ cho mì
ăn liền tôi có hết sẵn mẫu ở đây tôi
thấy nhóm nào giống nhóm nào thì tôi
không có gì để chấm cả mấy ông sẽ không
tự nghĩ tự làm nem mấy ông sẽ phải tự
nghĩ khá nhiều về cái tài liệu luôn
chị sẽ luận này
Ừ cái luận này tội đã ghi rõ nhá đó đã
làm được những gì làm trang web như thế
nào chạy được những cái gì mấy ông người
nói qua về cái hướng mở rộng với ông có
thể làm xuống mở rộng ngồi đây là có thể
làm tính năng nâng cao là nữa vân vân có
thể kèm theo lời cảm ơn cái này bởi vừa
đồ này nó là đồ án tốt nghiệp của của
sinh viên cũ của tôi nghe nó sẽ có cả
lời cảm ơn thầy cô thì cảm ơn các bạn gì
đó
Tiếp theo phần cuối này
ờ ờ phần cuối phân công công việc ngày
xí mấy ông phải liệt kê rõ ra thường là
tôi bảo mấy ông đi cái xong cái bảng ấy
là là ai đã làm phần phần nào phần ăn
Min phần khách hàng và nên bác em ạ
Và nếu liệt kê Đừng có liệt kê cả làm
word nhá tôi không quan tâm mày phải làm
Word PowerPoint có sử dụng đâu mày ông
liệt kê tính năng cụ thể hơn càng tốt
những bạn này làm tình năng này bạn lại
làm tính năng này mà ông nên ghi rõ làm
tình năm nào chứ đừng có kiểu bạn này đã
làm admin 30 phần trăm làm flan 40 phần
trăm chẳng hiểu cái gì cả đúng ạ nên để
kết hợp tính năng nhé
ý là cái phần thuật công công việc này
ra cái hôi đấy Tôi chấm điểm cho mình
xin tiền thôi mà còn bây giờ mấy ông này
ra tôi không biết chấm điểm như nào luôn
Ừ Nếu vài ông nào đó là một mình thì mấy
ông không cần có phần tấn công công việc
cũng được bỏ qua đi em đấy mình không
thấy là
tôi đang ốp cái à Vợ nhỉ Cái cách dạy
của tôi ở trường nghề cho mấy ông mấy
ông sẽ thấy à nó sẽ khác với việc với
ông mấy ông học trên lớp có tin nữa thế
mà Trừ khi mày ông đang học năm cuối thế
hệ giống giống một tí về cái vụ làm tài
liệu này à
em
làm đoán hay là làm
hóa đơn chi tiết hóa đơn chưa chết rồi
mà mình chưa hiểu ý bạn lắm
anh nữa à Bạn đang nói việc là đón hay
thì sẽ chi tiết hơn đồ ăn một thì ở đúng
nhưng mà à
Anh đoán hay thì sẽ mình sẽ không cho
các bạn làm cho máy bán hàng nữa đón hay
có rất nhiều đề tài có bạn chọn là nên
là phải toàn nhiệm vụ chứ không phải làm
những cái liên quan đến tin tức hay bán
hàng nữa bởi thực ra cái đấy được ra nó
hơi bị chán một tí và nó cũng chỉ có mỗi
lần này thì nhanh thôi nó còn đồ ăn hay
các bạn phải làm những bài cảm xúc tạp
hơn
à à
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình Mình định nói con tí
thôi mà tốn nhiều thời gian fake rồi
chắc là mình sẽ kiểm tra tiến độ lại
thêm một vài nhóm nữa đúng ạ Cho anh tầm
9 rưỡi cũng được các bạn có thắc mắc gì
về gái này thế bạn hỏi luôn còn không
thắc mắc là có nhiều ở Đồng nghĩa việc
là các bạn nếu hiểu không ạ hiểu thì bắt
đầu từ thử Ban ở sau rồi tôi lại bắt đầu
chấm từng nhóm về cái tài liệu đấy Hôm
nay thứ bảy không ạ Mà ông còn
3 ngày nữa Nếu không cần phải xong cái
tài liệu này tài liệu Nói chung là nó
hơi bị khắt khe mà tí nhưng mà đồ án mà
mày không phải làm mất ăn mất ngủ vì nó
thì nó mới là cái đoán Nhưng mà ông vừa
làm vừa chơi thì nó không Không về đồ ăn
em làm ăn mới ngủ với nó và mấy ông Nếu
mà quen với việc đấy rồi thực ra nó
không khó lắm đâu Tôi khẳng định là rất
nhiều ông từng khoe được thôi Bây giờ em
chẳng làm gì cả Đến Gần 23 tuần cuối em
ngồi học bơ em là cả cốc cả Word
PowerPoint Thế là xong hết
em phải có deride thúc đấy ông ạ
vì miếng ăn tết xong rồi nữa
em nấu ăn tết xong hết rồi ơi mà làm
à à
em
yên tâm vào máy ông làm đến đâu mà tôi
chữa đầy tội không khắc hay làm không
Ừ nếu mà ở chiến trường Thôi thôi mới
khác hay vậy trường tôi thuốc nhiều hơn
Còn mấy ông bây giờ
thước cũng vô vọng
à à
ừ ừ
Ê
mấy ông kia bắt đầu đuổi đuổi làm kịp à
Vậy chưa ạ
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình sẽ chậm nhá
Mấy ông có link này rồi Nếu có thể tham
khảo luôn này mày cái sơ đồ này lại nhé
Ừ tự nhiên tại sao có 23 cái xô đồ đấy
nhá
anh không rõ làm luôn không nhớ mấy ngày
luôn mày không xem lại ở quy trình bảo
vệ đồ này
quy trình bảo vệ đồ án này nữa để biết
được hôm bảo vệ tôi sẽ họ những cái gì
những cái này sẽ phải có trong Word thì
mấy ông làm đấy ạ ừ ừ
ừ ừ
số 2 ngõ 11 ổn thôi để mình sẽ sang nhóm
à
a13
ừ ừ
à à
ở ngoài đổi mật khẩu luôn ạ
Ừ ok
à à ừ nóng Mày hiểu không biết được có
dùng Facebook thì không trọng sĩ đấy nhỉ
tâm sự với
tôi tôi rút lại câu xịn rồi đổ sạch
ê ê
áo phông chữ
ừ ừ
về kĩ năng sao hả
cô
bạn kia làm vợ chưa làm xong nhà ạ thì
nó không phải à
Ừ thôi nói gì về vụ này sẽ chơi tôi sẽ
xem lại Tôi chat mà nhóm ảnh như thế nào
đã
anh ngắm mày hình được một người lắm
anh Alo hai người làm
à à khách hàng thì còn thiếu về giao
diện con à Admin để hoàn thiện rồi Ok từ
Xem bé lắm Mimi nghìn khách hàng đó mắt
quá
mày cũng không để dùm anh nhá Tôi tôi
cho tất cả mọi người cũng xem mày ông tự
biểu xấu hộ bạn thân mình buồn lắm
i Hai tay con nít à Thế à
Ừ tối giản mà không khách nhìn vào khách
chạy ngay Bố lấy một tối bạn
à à
Nghe danh mục quản lý chống lại không
biết để gì đây nhà sản xuất cái này hơi
nhược điểm thì các bạn với Sao lại sắp
xếp lại à
à à các bạn phải nên đẩy cái quản lý đến
Hà lên trên cùng người thứ người ta mới
vào ngày sắc 1 tâm đấy hơn hơn là những
kể quản lý cái này không phải sắp xếp
lại cái đấy
hả cái mục tìm kiếm cái gì đấy ạ Chưa
hiểu cái này
tìm kiếm ở đây rồi nhập thêm này tím kéo
à
Đó cũng là một tí cho cái danh ngôn tình
kiện này mình hơi khó hiểu đi
xem này
trong giao diện da xịn mỗi tội là mất
thử cái máy new thôi à à
cho nên cần nút duyệt nốt Hủy ngay đây
nè
khi sex
anh nói chung là mày Ông vẫn đang làm à
Anh vẫn đang làm đầy đủ tính năng thêm
sửa xóa Tôi thấy thế là ổn rồi đoán một
thấy ổn rồi của tôi còn đồ ăn hay ấy thì
bất kỳ cái gì mà kiểu dạng kiểu gây khó
dùng người dùng kiểu dạng mà không tốt
cho người dùng kiểu đạn sự đơn đơn mới
đặt lại đẩy cuối này thì kiểu gì đón hay
tôi sẽ nhắc nhở và tôi sẽ còn nhiều Tôi
sẽ
không chấp nhận được không Không 13 tuổi
cho người là ok ok cái mã này đấy mã này
ông cho đấy tự động ta mà mẹ linh tinh
nó sẽ thử mã đấy bạn ạ
à à
ô ô Dell
không cho bạn tôi làm tăng nhé phải lấy
mã từ
hay đi Ở đây ai đi lại nhỉ cái đơn 2
khi đàn bà vẫn hay đặt vào ngày 11 tháng
không phải sửa thời gian đơn này trông
hơi khó hiểu
Ừ
ok rồi
313 thế cực đại tương đối của nó trừ
khoản là giao diện bên kia đi cho da bé
ông ấy tự sửa thôi
À mà quên tắt nhỏ 14 Tôi đang chấm khá
nhanh lướt qua hỏi tôi không thể chấm
được từng dòng cốt của mấy ông chết đón
Hay thôi sẽ có thể chấm từng làm cốt mà
ông hơn đấy nếu anh ấy ông theo Facebook
mà Mấy ông cốt được mấy ông mà cốt chưa
cửa loạn hết lên mỗi ông một ngôn ngữ rõ
chịu
à à à à
Xin
chào bấm được này lửa
Ồ vậy à
Ừ ok
Em
hãy nêu có bấm đâu
xe lửa
ê ê
tương không nên tơ rồi Bây giờ bạn đã
xóa rồi thì pho mà
Ừ
nó năn nỉ Hải Phòng nữa
Em có biết không em ạ Không được rồi à
anh nữa rồi
I had for play hôm đây
Ê
mày Làm lại nè thấy bù
four-input 200 lít sao không bấm rồi
nghỉ à
em không bấm được đấy hay cho tôi mà đẹp
vậy em tôi ở nhỏ lên tới à
ở Hawaii check bằng Rocket à
số tự động á
ừ ừ
à à
đã xóa này đi
em không bấm được cả nhà
I fall apart
nữa đến kẻ vô set là mấy thuốc này
cho tôi edit này
có thêm một bên bút Ngô Quốc Tuân ở ngay
cái này đi
ok này
khoa học của từng đôi tay rồi
xe
tải đẩy xuống dưới vậy để có tuần chứ
gửi nhé á à à
à à
À mà quên Quê Ngoại
đi thi Thách Thức
à à
ở
những lửa lắm
anh ạ
anh đã không ảnh Sếp tôi quên xừ mất vừa
nhận xét gì nhỉ
à à
ở ngã tư không được anh sẽ từ đi đây
Okay I
Xin lỗi i
à à
Ừ ừ
anh biết ấn vào đây là lấy tài khoản rồi
nhưng mà
bài hát Duyên
Em nhớ anh Em thử thử cái kia không được
làm chung công kênh nha Vậy chưa Ok em
ai có bấm vào sân mỹ đẩu uống được thôi
đúng không ạ bây giờ lại đấy lửa
anh không rõ làm rồi tôi không bật nó
cái sắp Mỹ Đấy không phải tạo hình cái
biết tin xe tuyến xe buýt đi
xe hơi lạ đoạn đấy tôi hơi lạ lẫm sao ok
chống xì Tết
Ừ cái này tôi không nhớ mấy ông ấy làm
đã ta bây kiểu gì để mà đập được một cái
vụ này không nhớ đâu
em xem lại phát quà YouTube bạn ơi đó
Ừ để mình giật Alipas nóng này chưa nhỉ
Như diệt rồi
anh Bởi vì nếu phải lừa thông tin để đạt
được những cái kiểu tùy chọn này ông ạ
mở máy Tâm
à à
Ừ kệ ai 10 là gì nhỉ hết cái này tăng
giá từng loại này cố định luôn toàn bộ
em à ok
Ừ cái này ai ai nhỉ
Ừ chắc là có không chắc thế nhưng mà
phải đặt tên nó rõ hơn như kiểu như này
không ổn tên rõ hơn hình dung nhìn tao
mới hiểu luôn là cái này à được phép có
đá
cái này không kiểu ví dụ là ở tháp Eyes
hát Chuyện girl 2k gió ở
Ừ Ok Thế còn
ở bên này thì à họ đi thêu
à à
khi họ Trần size ông Lư sai trong này
option
để lưu lại như này kìa
Ừ cái này là không liên quan tính tiền
anh chắc là bỏ qua chỉ cần lưu là ốp
trần nghe được cũng được
à à
Ừ để để tôi thử nhé
có thêm này là do hàng không
em bận mà sang chi tiết này này đun này
20 50
bí ẩn thế luôn đó Nhấn nút rồi cái Ngó
mày bị sao ấy do mấy tôi nhỉ
Em
đỡ heo
à à
Anh Không thần thông báo thành công thì
cả
ở những Chắc trêu
cài đặt nhiều thế à
à à
ô hô hấp Nó bảo thành công giờ nào sau
đây biết rồi đúng không
à à
I Nếu lại hơi còn á thì lại trong trong
giỏ hàng như thế nào nhé
a cho hai thằng Ốc Sên giống hệt nhau
thì mấy kiểu
cho mấy cả + tăng số lượng lên nó cũng
được ngày nay thằng trước tiên là bình
thường nó về Hoàng cũng đã làm kiểu này
cũng được không sao Thế cũng được rồi à
Ừ Ok bạn này làm như thế này bạn đang ốp
cho mỗi
bởi vì ở đây là bạn lại bắn đồ uống sẽ
ốp tới chỗ này luôn hỗ trợ khuôn rồi
luôn không bán được những cái gì khác
nữa Nhưng còn mình sai lại đưa mày đá
ạ Nó không nhỉ ngoài đường với đã
mình nghĩ là cái này thì ra cũng tương
đối cũng được
anh làm sao
anh ở bên là biệt thự bến An Minh Châu
à à
Ừ cái này nếu mà liên quan đến việc là
bởi vì bởi vì mai là bạn này đang làm đồ
uống
anh hả
anh làm sao để nhập số lượng từ bàn phím
á thì cái này các bạn phải làm SEO kiểu
lưu lại giọng mảnh đây các bạn sẽ lưu
lại dạng Màng ở đây Thằng ngày dán được
cái mã gì đó thằng này gắn mã gì đó Ở
đây các bạn nhập nhập nhập vào Ấn Nút
cập nhật thì nó sẽ ra số lượng này sẽ
tương ứng với các mã của thằng này để mà
cập nhật cho thằng ngày tháng ngày
Thương mã hài cập nhật thằng này khá
lằng nhằng lên đấy
ờ ờ
mẹ con mình đang nói dở thì nếu nếu mà
bạn mà chuyển qua bán quần áo này sẽ
phức tạp hơn bởi vì may bạn đang bán
uống thì ra nó là xổ số lượng lớn thoải
mái
Các bạn cứ lưu Úc chân thoải mái được
không cần mạng kiểu trách chung cậu đã
hết hàng hay chưa Vân bán quần áo thì nó
liên quan cả sai rồi màu các thứ lăng
nhăng hơn rất nhiều
ví dụ là kéo màu đỏ nó chịu size mờ sẽ
đồ rồi không còn xét nhé bạn cái đoạn
này đó là cực Còn cái này đồ uống thì
mấy ông pha được thì pha không ạ trước
khi báo hết đá
ông kể
ở nhà thuốc ốp cả này xuống đây là đúng
anh không đăng nhập được ngồi kiểm tra
gì đó giờ
bí mật khẩu cái nào gì em nhỉ
ừ ừ
ở nhà nộm
I s12
hi hi
à à
anh
nghe coi phim không biết có chuyện chấm
than 20
Ừ Ok Sao shipping order
nhà tiền kinh order
Ừ cái này ô đúng không của đất này
ăn Tết
khi enable disable
cũng được
em nghe cái này thì em hiểu
anh em hiểu thôi chứ lưu lại trong đây
bên người ta nhìn qua người ta không
hiểu đó Em ghi rõ là ai áp chuẩn cả hấp
dẫn sẽ ổn hơn
khi được mình thấy nhóm này có vẻ ổn rồi
bảo vệ được một rồi
15 16
à à
khi xu
10 nv luôn ạ ok
à à
khi
root password
anh tí nhé
à à
Ừ lúc nào root password
a a
sôi để chống đi cho nhanh
ở đây sẽ là nhóm 16A
à à
chị
đã tầm bậy
mà mong trò hot nhạc à
à à
thay đổi góc sạch lỗ ròng 33 had done
khi ngồi làm mới kiểu lằng nhằng phết
ở chỗ cái này cũng giống mơ với xe rồi
cũng giống giống không
chú ý thế này không đúng nhĩ phải It's
at thì nó chuẩn hơn
à à
chú chó
Ừ ok
Ừ nếu mà em muốn cậu kiểm tra cách khác
để ít ngược em đi được
em học sinh giao diện
a123 đi hạnh
anh kể đăng nhập thì sao
khi đăng nhập đăng ký này
AE xem vui vẻ ạ
ê kê Bấm mẹ xem chi tiết này ồ mua đồ
này lại mua đồ đấy
anh cũng lại chọn kích cỡ có thử thử
biết là mấy hôm nay YouTube rồi gì
khi có thông tin tức nè A
deeper freelance đưa thông tin
thông tin a á địa chỉ địa chỉ giao đúng
không
a Model status lưu lại cầu được xác suất
chỉ có nhiều nhiều
thì tại sao lưu hệ một con tim này hơi
sai với việc mình Đạt mà mình đặt à đúng
nhóm nhạc nhóm 16 ngủ ngon mình đạp mình
đặt à nếu mà mình ta thì mình sẽ phải
bác ạ
có kích cỡ mà ngon
các em à xã hội đợi đi thế không có
thiếu thiếu rồi
Ừ Ông ngoại đang làm đây nhỉ
à à
ừ ừ
em có làm loạn này nhớ thiếu rồi thế làm
sao mà hóa đơn chi tiết Nếu lại thằng
kia ở đặt cỡ bánh gì
ở đó
à mà thưa Nếu mà cậu bánh Thay đổi sao
phải tăng giá
bộ phim
I gotta pha này ở đâu đấy à
à à
xe ô tô cad này không dậy nè
xe
hơi sai người sai này vẫn lên này một
không lưu lại được xay nha Chào tạm bỏ
sai em ạ là bộ sau thế này đi
ok ở chỗ ở bên giao diện khách hàng vậy
mùng mẹ Thế thì sang bên anh em pin rồi
mà
à à
à à ừ ừ
I am in e
khi sex
chị Hà lấy không Trước tôi nhớ không lầm
mà hôm trước tôi không hack được một mấy
ông mà mình mấy ông không lưu lại DB rồi
đã không có gì hết đăng nhập cũng đăng
nhập vào gì
ờ ờ
đã xem Hãy xem cốc rồi
I mean
phụ trách admin tạm bỏ lại đi
hết đơ không ai ship được khi từng đoạn
không biết đâu được nó
à à
ừ ừ
vì anh nghĩ đơn hàng new
chưa muốn cưới à
anh kể phản hồi luôn à nó phản hồi được
cho Kim hơi nhiều nhưng mà cái á mày cái
tính năng kia tuần liên hoàn thiện trước
đã đúng không ạ
ở bên nhóm ai cần sửa lại bên đặt đơn
nữa xong đơn cho ngon
AT117 nào
à à
ăn cháo thun tự kỷ
Ăn
Gì Đây
à à Ừ
ok shop
ồ ồ ảnh hấp dẫn
ừ ừ
em cũng chia nhiều loại Phết Xem lại bài
thi Kể nhà tiếp
à à
cô không mấy ông cứ để phải giao diện
làm gì tôi có chấm ra diện mấy rồi nó
diện đẹp mà tính năng mà không thể được
để tội đổi xuống thôi
I kept Alistar có Tử Di
bạn để làm mày ngủ hay cấp
cũng được
ừ ừ
anh đi theo ở đâu
I say luôn này
à Nhưng cái này không có sai hay lại sao
dữ liệu lỗi bắt đầu có say này sai
ở xa Nhưng mà chắc không có mâu Thế đã
chọn sai thôi cũng được của một cách
tương đối
Ok vẽ sai bạn này cũng chả thay đổi giá
luôn em Sao táo không ảnh hưởng lắm chứ
Thì XXL cái gì đó còn cái cỡ bánh như
bạn vừa nãy thì chắc là mệt hơn bạn kia
thấy bánh cỡ S với bánh cỡ L giá dài như
nhau để chết chết tiền một là thiệt rồi
cái thằng mua ít 2 thìa phòng ngồi nhiều
trong một trong hai Nhưng mà nếu mà
khách hàng mà vào đấy Nhìn thấy dòng cho
kiểu gì nó giảng môi mua nhiều hết chả
Thảo đi mua Ít ra vẫn thế cơ à
khi sex
Hà Tĩnh
Min Ah
khi đăng nhập
ừ ừ
à à
hệ
thống kê ngồi xuống chị mãi
anh cũng mẹ cũng không ạ
Ừ hai cái lớn về nhỏ ông được rồi À cái
này chưa biết làm gì không ạ
Giờ thống kê những đơn bị bỏ bom để làm
ăn cũng được mà kiểu doanh thu tổn thất
thì là thường người ta sẽ đôi khi làm
chia cái này cũng thể nhiều màu nữa có
hiện nhiều cái nữa các bạn hãy cân nhắc
tranh thu gần nhất là so với doanh thu
dự kiến sắp tới Vân để mà ước tính nhiều
cái hay má á từ điển chứng khó chịu nghỉ
cá ít à Có cái ít mà
cô
nhân viên Nghệ sĩ Đơn giản thôi sản phẩm
mấy cái thứ ba quản lý sản phẩm của
những đơn hàng quan trọng hơn các bạn để
lên trên cùng đúng không ạ
cơ sở thích nóng này thì mà chú tâm và
cả cái Thiên thị tiền tệ hay
Xem tivi Play hodo cho mày cái này các
bạn ghi rõ là tìm kiếm theo tên là tìm
kiếm gì đó tên gì đó dễ hiểu hơn ở đây
là giống như thế này hợp lý hơn cái sắp
xếp nhé
em sắp xếp thời gian nhà những ai đi này
mấy ông để đi Tôi không biết đúng hay
sai sao anh đi ở đây tự động tăng À cái
này nó phải trên này nha à
à à
em nhìn ô tô
em
bán đúng rồi đi Cộng Một ngày hơi sai
mình phải đúng theo cái mã của đơn thì
nó còn hơn mình sẽ cho khách hàng thì mã
đơn và khách hay sẽ khi mà gọi cho mấy
nhân viên đấy nó sẽ đọc mã đơn của họ
lên họ thường là như thế hơn là thông
tin cá nhân đấy mấy ông cha theo mã đơn
thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn
em muốn bắt đầu học bên di chu trên J2
thì bạn ạ Ý bạn là học khóa của mình hai
họp khóa học người khác khóa học người
khác thì vào server của củ chi chu để mà
học thôi còn vào khoa học của mình thì
Ừ bạn cứ xem video của mình học thôi con
để làm đồ án thì các bạn nên điền con
đăng kí bây giờ thì ra bây giờ đến dùm
hay mất rồi
Ừ
nó này chọn cách tương đối rồi ok
à à
Hồ Ngọc Hà
em nằm 20
ở
nhóm kia sân nhóm này đã xin bảo vệ đợt
mục được hai rồi
15 20 cập nhật lần cuối là 16 tháng 1
đổi xe mã xem nó có người ta chưa
Hôm
qua nhắn ẩn Quế nhóm này nó em mất tích
hết rồi đậu xanh thì sao đã
anh ngắm hai bắt đầu một ẩn số rồi à
em gái
ờ ờ nhóm 21
à à
U21 Anh
khi ngủ
ừ ừ
Ừ ok ở thì mà dọn hàng các thứ
vợ chồng về một mình
chị xem bên admin xem anh ạ
khi sex à à
à à khi bạn đặt tên file được ở Tôi
không thích tao nhắn nữa viết hoa nửa
kiểu gạch dưới ở Nga về sau nên thống
nhất cách đặt tên là hợp lý hơn
Ừ đúng rồi Bây giờ làm sao có thời gian
dạy lại cho người mới nữa Sang đồ ăn hay
thì học tiếp là học nâng cao của TP như
là nếu mà nếu mà học cơ bản với P thì
đúng em phải xem lại video từ đầu thôi
em còn về sau thì nhớ là sử mà dậy xong
hết hai khóa này tới về xong mà vẫn có
nhiều người gạ tôi
dạy lại thì chắc là sẽ có khóa thứ hai
nhưng mà đấy về sau tình không ạ không
hứa rồi mấy cái đấy
xem mì ông đông đông tí thì còn có hướng
dậy lại dạy lại mụn trong 12 bạn thì kèm
trực tiếp về hơn đỡ mất công người quay
lại cả video cái thứ anh nữa Vì tôi nghĩ
à và cái cái khóa mới cái video lại khá
đầy đủ đấy và khá nhiều cái chia sẻ rồi
tôi không biết là khóa sau chưa chải
được cái gì nữa
em ở ngoài đều mã hóa mật khẩu
đậu xanh
cho tôi lại và sửa code vậy
I had mi lễ
anh lặng im im
a Law in sẽ nhảy đến á
bộ xử lý luôn trong pha này ok
ừ ừ
à à
hệ thống kê
10 cái gì đấy nên chị tiền tệ hội Vì hơn
nhỉ Cái này là khá nhà
khi nhận lên hiển thị và nó thêm nữa ổn
hơn
[âm nhạc]
anh nghe nên thiếu format gửi tiền này
I fall phạm còn khó rồi nghỉ à
anh làm gì có kho đó à có
Ở đây chỉ lưu lại đã bán đúng không nên
việc đã bán này Mất công cập nhật lại
lắm nên thống kê luôn trong order thì nó
hợp lý hơn
Ừ cái này thì à với cái này thì cô Đắc
Ai đi với à cứ sợ mời đi nên nên là khóa
chính nếu là sự em muốn làm cho
một khách Hà chị thì đánh giá một sản
phẩm một lần Còn nếu như em muốn làm
theo kiểu một khách hàng thì đánh giá đi
đánh giá lại một sản phẩm theo kiểu là
nó đã đặt sản phẩm nào rồi nó được phép
đánh giá lại sản phẩm đấy Thì ra là nó
liên quan đến nó liên quan nhiều đến
việc là trong cái đơn order code thì
theo ấy tùy theo này lượng rating luôn
đâu lại được còn đây anh thấy là bạn đã
không có khóa chính gì cả Có thể thế thì
về sau nó lại xung đột dữ liệu kiểu ở đó
lặp lại thì vẫn đặt lại được
Ừ để loại
Ăn trái cây không Tí kho Này là gì nhỉ
khó này không biết kho này như nào
anh em
Ừ anh đâu không biết để kho này lưu kiểu
gì à số số lượng này đúng à số lượng đấy
à
vì số lượng này là số lượng trong kho
nhà
từ ngày số lượng lúc đầu nhập về cho cái
số lượng lại khá là ngày à
Ừ Ok bạn ấy cũng tính nhiều trường hợp
rồi nhưng mà chính vì nhiều trường hợp
nhà nó sẽ sinh ra khá nhiều vấn đề nữa
là xử lý nhiều vấn đề nữa máy tính sao
đi à
ở nhóm 21 ở ngoài Nhóm 2 theo tôi chấm
được thêm 23 nhóm nữa thôi nó sẽ mà
à Ừ mới nhóm này dưới nước ạ Chồng nhanh
hả Sao ạ
anh rồi chấm nhỏ mồm cũng nói ông rất
trường ấy
ở
ngoài mất tích rồi à
I can fix
à à
ừ ừ
ở Châu Á
hồ cá
ở phòng 73
[âm nhạc]
à à
bộ phim lút hết đâu
cho tôi không biết Hà mày không mấy bạn
nhiều lúc làm tốt Ngạc nhiên lắm rồi
chẳng biết mấy hả mày tồn tại được
chồng 73 Ok vệ ba báo lỗi tại đây
em không có xin cáp nên không nhìn thấy
ra cái đấy à cách để mà mày không làm
ở vùng cao được cách mấy ông làm cái này
đúng không chị cầm là
nhẹ được
Ừ
cái này có hoặc không sẽ lấy tay bên
phải nghe được
32 ch nhớ bị vỡ không tí thì chả rõ nội
dung này gì đấy
inbox đoạn này không được rồi nhỉ import
ấy không được đâu luôn nhỉ cái này
import iPhone mà chị
ừ ừ
anh không đánh giá không vậy
bố mẹ không Nghĩa
bài hát về tinh Ford chồng hết buồn cười
Ừ cái này thiếu khi kết nối thiếu chỉ à
khi thiếu chỉ rồi
mô hình ảnh áo kiểu bị như thế này nó
trình ut8 thiếu không phải do trình
duyệt tốt Để đó nha trình duyệt của tôi
chỗ mới nhé
anh kể về thử sang 15mi được giải mã
ở ngã tư thêm giọng Hà nhỉ Thế cho anh
300 nên hiển thị số sản phẩm có sẵn này
nó giữ spa Mã
Ê mấy ông thay đổi hàng xong nếu trảm
báo thành công thì đậu xanh Đây là 225
à à
chú ý
chưa bao giờ
Ai có file
ăn cá nóc Sao nghỉ à
Ở nhóm 2 mà
đi
nhậu mày bị ốp cái sửa lại
sợ đừng dẫn
à à
anh access không
lỗi lỗi Note II
Em nói sao
trẻ sơ sinh
à à
I
Pray
kẻ được gọi này nhưng mà do là bạn đấy
lại gọi đến thằng tại vị trí được không
à à
Hà Nội lại dòng 11
ở khu sơ info
a slack
thế Arena thằng Tôi đang đăng nhập lại
là một thằng nào đó
anh ra vị như này không sao không sao ạ
em bỏ qua họ đi
đầy thông tin nhắn tin cho thấy gì à
thôi sửa lại cái tính đến 1 giờ tôi đang
nhập và của thằng khác
à à
khi họ tên
ở phòng mẹ hay
không
nó ok ok sớ
anh sex nó bị sao nhỉ Chắc là do cái
domaine nốt đúng không nói chuyện nhé em
O2 + sách đúng không
Ê mày có thích không nổi dậy ngon
à à
10 cm của ông Nguyễn Thị mà à
ý
là cái có
thêm về cháu ạ
à à Rồi ok
vãi chưởng
ok ok
à à
khi gặp mà tội không còn tâm giao diện
đâu bỏ qua đặt hàng trong ngày được này
để trả mày ăn đi nhé ạ
có gì vậy
ok à
ha ha ha Này
cơ cấu hình chi tiết
có giá trị xã ổn nhỉ đặt hàng rồi có cái
liên quan đến Cố ấy nhỉ
ở đâu để xem lại phát nhanh
à à
Ừ cái này có chọn cấu hình đâu nhỉ
Ừ cái nào chọn cấu hình vậy
cơ cấu hình cấu hình trực tiếp
Ừ
ông hãy lưu lại cái này à
Hì hì ngờ bị
đã bảo tôi xem
38 nói đùa mà hai ở lúc tôi xơi có vấn
đề à Giờ lại bên anh nhỉ
ở
cái đoạn này rất phức tạp mà thôi tạm
xóa đi thế là xóa đây đã ta bây nhá sợ
ra đây luôn rồi bạn này nữa không biết
anh đi sớm là bị lỗi sao tự nhiên nó
thành gian trong như anh
anh không biết
Ừ để xem lại
file inbox nhé
cho iPad của nhóm này à
à à
anh đọc của mình ở TP
ở nhóm mày lưu lại chuẩn và nhạc chờ đợi
xem nào
khi sex I Connect Unicode bóng ma à ở
lại đây nào ạ
à à
ở lại được rồi ở đâu
em mãi không được không được mà lại
không biết tại sao anh inbox của của em
bây giờ có bị lỗi nữa nha
ừ ừ
Ừ thôi cái đấy tính sau thì sao chứ
không sao đâu
à Vì sao các bạn để mô đến mua trên máy
các bạn thôi không Không chạy xe máy
mình đâu Cứ kệ rồi ok xe máy năm mi nào
ạ
cô nhân viên này
- ông lão khẩu mãi hoặc
ngồi sữa
I love in đây
À nhầm Sợ quá Chị nói suy đoán
không ra được
ở bên kia bằng em yêu à
à à
ở đây
Xin vui lòng nhập mã
à à
Ừ ok
Ừ rồi
anh không diễn mã lỗi
cho mấy bạn này đang bị lỗi mỗi cái sân
thôi mình có bạn phải sửa lại cái vụ này
see More
a
fine Plus includes head
có hay không tồn tại
Em không tin về cái biến ơi bé này được
gọi đâu nhỉ
khi bé đó gọi được gọi đâu đó không ạ
anh chưa xong à Anh thấy chỗ cũng giao
diện cũng cơ bản rồi sao phải sợ hơn một
tí nữa được nó à
thế này trong cũng tương đối rồi
thường đối hội từng nói
vì chị mà Vào diện nó hơi thử đầy đủ
tính năng thêm sữa xóa cũng tương đối
với mình làm Mà quản lý đơn nữa là xong
Vì sao vẫn bảo vệ đường đồng anh anh cứ
tạm Để Đời Một nhé nhưng mà chú vẫn phải
ngồi làm tài liệu một mình đã cũng mệt
đấy
chị sẽ tự nhiên nhảy sáng hôm sau
Ừ Ok bây giờ cũng 9 rưỡi rồi Các bạn có
thắc mắc gì em nhỉ Không mình sẽ chấm
nốt trầm nốt những nóng nhóm còn lại sau
thì tí mình sẽ chấm một mình sẽ Liệt kê
lại cao các bạn cứ
em chuẩn bị tinh thần để mà bảo vệ đợt 1
đúng không
nói chung và bắt được rồi tuần sau thì
mình cứ tạm chốt là mười 19 ngày 19 tuần
sau mình những cái nhóm bảo vệ đợt 1 này
mình sẽ ngẫu nhiên một vài nhóm để bảo
vệ thơ bảo vệ thở đây mình sẽ
chắc là mình sẽ gọi à Gọi qua mít Google
mít cũng được đúng không hôm trước là
thấy dụng Google mít Mình thấy cũng khá
mượt được cho là gọi được mà chia sẻ
được màn hình không cần phải run gì đâu
nha đấy thì mình qua Google mít rồi đó
mình sẽ họ mình sẽ để các bạn trình bày
nói chung và mình sẽ nói cụ thể hơn các
bạn cần phải trình bày những cái gì buổi
sáng nữa Nhờ các bạn cứ phải chuẩn bị
chốt được word phải chốt đã rồi mình sẽ
chị sẽ yêu cầu các bạn làm Powerpoint
dựa theo về Word đấy Sao PowerPoint được
nhanh và nhắn rồi không yêu cầu các bạn
tự làm màu mè thì cứ mỗi tiêu đề rồi Các
bạn nói trai được thì ở
Ừ mình khi mà gọi gọi như thế Mình không
cần các bạn phải có camera nhìn mặt các
bạn làm gì cả chỉ cần chia sẻ màn hình
là được nhưng mà cũng hạn chế việc làm
mấy ông nhìn vào màn hình em ấy Không
đọc nha Mà không trực tiếp này rồi không
tượng quản lý được mấy ông được mấy ông
có nhìn nhìn chăm chăm mà tờ giấy nhìn
mà màn hình ông ngồi đọc lại những cái
thứ trên màn hình không nhưng mà tôi sẽ
họ rất nhiều câu rồi mấy ông Nếu phải
trả lời nên là không khóm à Chuẩn bị
được hết đâu ông ạ
Anh bảo vệ được
anh
nói chung là cố bảo vệ sao cho ôn để mà
khi mà ra ngoài đi làm các bạn sẽ không
bị ngại khi mà phỏng vấn mấy cái kiểu cứ
trình trước đám đông với vân vân đó
ngoại các bạn sẽ có thêm kỹ năng
để tui ở Dân công nghệ mình thì không
cần phải nói cậu dạng như đã cấp giống
tôi nhưng mà Mấy ông cũng phải nói được
nhận cái mới ông đã la nếu mà ông nát
ngữ hoặc có vấn đề gì đó Khi mà không
nói được những cái Hữu Nghĩa là mày nó
rằng mình chứng minh được và mình là
thằng làm nó không ạ nên là tôi nghĩ là
cái đấy cái yếu tố cần thiết để mà làm
Ừ nếu không hiểu không ạ Mấy ông không
không nói với tôi là kiểu em là thuộc
dạng ít nói em em sống nội tâm luôn vân
nên em không muốn bảo vệ thì ra đấy
Thiện mới ông thôi thì vì tiền ngành này
không cần phải giao tiếp nhiều nhưng mà
bắt buộc những cái cái đấy kỹ năng mà Kỹ
năng nó khác
những thói quen rất nhiều người sống nội
tâm vẫn có thể làm thầy giáo được cơ Với
họ họ chỉ là nói những cái thứ không
phải về bản thân mình
nói nói với bản thân mình mới sống nội
tâm
còn có nói về toàn bộ những cái biết là
những cái mình đã làm thì nó dỡn bình
thường mình phải nói được nghĩ được đấy
ông ạ Không cần nói trôi chảy tôi không
đáng giá mấy ông cần nói chơi chạy mấy
ông bà nhắn ngữ hay cái gì đó không xa
nhau với điều kiện mấy ông vẫn thấy
anh vẫn phải giải thích được cái bảo vệ
chương trình là phải nói đồng ý tưởng
của mình và phải nói được mình đã làm
được những gì ít nhận như thế
ở đâu ạ Đấy Ít nhất mình không phải làm
được điều đấy
Ờ Ờ
mình cũng sẽ vẫn livestream trên trên
youtube này thôi chẳng qua lại chia theo
dạng là là qua run nữa nên là các bạn
vẫn có thể xem mấy bạn rút kinh nghiệm
và sự giữ những nhóm đầu Đương nhiên
mình sẽ ưu ái hơn là mình sẽ hỏi nhẹ
nhàng hơn cả nhóm sau mình sẽ càng gắt
và sẽ còn những câu hỏi mà nhóm đầu sẽ
không Hỏi nhầm sau mới hỏi nên là mấy
ông đừng có nghĩa là nhóm đầu hỏi hết
rồi tôi chuẩn bị tâm lý hết rồi Không
không chuyện đấy không ạ ạ
à à
anh nói chung mà Mấy ông có sẵn sàng
tinh thần cho một tuần rồi nhá Đúng
không Mình mình đã nói cái này trước khi
Tết rồi mà ông ăn tết ngon rồi về đến
lúc màu hồng lại đúng không ạ
anh nói lắp thì nói cái gì trông mượt đã
với sữa mình thấy được ra nói lắp và
thường người ta do tự ti của không biết
nói gì trước họ sẽ thường bị lắp thì
cách khắc phục ở họ nên Thứ nhất là nói
nói chậm phải luyện quen nói chậm nữa đã
Cứ nói kiểu từng từ một ý đấy thứ hai
biết hãy chuẩn bị trước những cái mình
sẽ nói ờ
từ kinh nghiệm của mình thì mình không
có kinh nghiệm lắm Bởi vì khẳng định
mình là một thằng không chuẩn bị trước
một cái gì đáng cả phí dạy này mình cũng
nghĩ gì Nói Đấy mình là thằng giỏi ứng
biến hơn các bạn không khóm à luyện được
cái giỏi ứng biến khi mà các bạn chỉ cầu
kinh nghiệm chưa trải nhiều thế nên là
các bạn phải chuẩn bị văn minh mình chả
nhiều mình dậy cái anh nhiều mình nói
nhiều ra bây giờ mình cư bật ra thôi
Ô thế Mình không cần chuẩn bị cái gì cả
từ nhỏ
thì các bạn sẽ nhận ra khi mà đặc biệt
quay mình ngoài đời Các bạn sẽ thấy mình
có thể bất ra bảo mình lên đừng phát
biểu một cái gì đó đột nhiên kiểu mời
mình lên để mà nói cái gì đó mình có thể
bằng được thì bởi vì mình có cũng tương
đối biết cách ứng biến Thôi mình cũng
xem nhiều MC các thứ thứ người đã gọi
không biết không anh Xuân Bắc một đêm
thì những hãy rất giống biến ngoài rất
Hà xuất khẩu thành thơ được
sau khi thì ạ
ở những các bạn cái đấy khó luyện hơn
thế này là thế nên là mình không yêu cầu
các bạn mấy cái vụ đấy các bạn là dân
công nếu mà hướng đến dân công nghệ thì
mấy bạn chỉ cần chuẩn bị chuẩn bị trước
các bạn nói lại những thứ mình đã chuẩn
bị ngoạn có những câu hỏi thiên nhiên
mình hỏi một cái bất ngờ thì các bạn có
thể sẽ hơi lung tung tí nha các bạn chỉ
cần nói lại những cái thứ các bạn đã làm
là ổn thôi nó ý tưởng các bạn ở được rồi
Ừ không sao không ai ăn thịt mấy ông đâu
mọi người cũng chẳng mất cái gì cả tôi
là mày mất thời gian nhiều hơn Ngon mấy
ông làm một ít thôi là tôi khẳng định
tôi làm nhiều hơn thế nên là mày Ông cứ
thoải mái đi
Ừ ok thì nhớ
tạm Hôm nay thấy không họ gì mấy chắc là
mấy ông
Ừ nếu chả thấy tự đi hết rồi nên trốn
hết rồi
em buổi sau nhé á
em buổi sau tôi tin mấy ông có hoa nhiều
câu hỏi hơn Bởi sợ cứ chuẩn bị Câu Hỏi
do đó buổi sau đi hỏi trước đi để tôi
trả lời trước Thì hôm bảo vệ mày Ông còn
biết cái mà trả lời đúng không biết cái
mà tôi sẽ hỏi nhé
Xin chào bạn ạ